Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen guten Morgen Tim.
Wie reagieren denn eigentlich die Hörer auf äh Facebook gibt's jetzt ausreichend Beitragsinteraktion?
Beitragsreichweite haben wir,
Zweitausenddreihundertundsiebenundvierzig.
Logbuch Netzpolitik, äh hunderteinundsiebzig äh Folgen werden im Kasten sein, wenn wir diese Sendung hier abgeschlossen haben und zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ihr das hört, ist es ja dann auch schon soweit
Ja, äh wir begrüßen natürlich wieder hier alle Hörerinnen und Hörer aufs herzlichste, auch wenn das mit dem Beitragsinteraktion noch nicht so läuft. Also das war jetzt so ein bisschen, also du hast da ja so schon schon so eine,
fast schon pathologische Affinität diesem Facebook Thema. Das geht mir ja irgendwie.
Ich.
Bisschen so ein bisschen an mir vorbei. Das äh weißt du, ich habe da so ein Bulletimement irgendwie so. Facebook, das das schießt wirklich,
Matrix-Style, dreidimensional, so direkt an mir vorbei.
Weiß, ich weiß, es ist auch eine sehr arrogante, alter Mann äh Position, die man so im Internet haben kann, ne, immer so dieses äh nerdige Nase-Rümpfen, über alles äh was nicht schon vor dreißig Jahren auf dem Rechner lief
aber na ja, ist halt so.
Ja äh ich weiß es ja auch nicht. Also ich äh ja.
Also jetzt hast du deine Beitragsreichweite, die du dir gewünscht hast, hast du ja bekommen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was Beitragsreite ist.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wodurch äh keiner weiß, was was das ist. Ich weiß auch nicht, was eine Beitragsinteraktion ist. Es.
Also eigentlich wollte ich ja, was ich ja eigentlich haben wollte, war äh gefällt mir Angaben. Da haben wir aber nicht genug. Und ähm was war's äh.
Ist total gaga.
Das ist total skurril, ja. Es ist aber ich meine, da bildet's ich finde das krass, also.
Weißt du was mich persönlich am meisten stört?
Dass es das gibt.
Nee, also, sagen wir mal so, ich finde ja generell das Angebot einer Plattform, so Community-Features bereitzustellen. Fiech aber überhaupt nicht falsch,
Also das äh will nicht sagen, aber äh grundsätzlich finde ich so dieses Versprechen von Facebook gar nicht so schlecht. Ich bin nur mit der Ausführung,
ziemlich unzufrieden. Also ich weder weder gefällt mir dieser Einheitslook.
Also man man kann sich da irgendwie gar nicht so richtig ähm austoben und dem Ganzen nicht so die eigene äh Nestwärme verpassen. Das ist so das eine,
Ich will jetzt auch gar nicht über das User-Interface verstehe ich nicht, ist mir zu kompliziert und so weiter, aber diese ganzen Regeln und Abläufe,
entsprechend nicht meinem Kommunikationsbedürfnis,
Also die Art und Weise, wie ich da irgendwie in Kontakt treten äh kann und, und, und, und. Die Hälfte der Seite ist gefühlt mit mit Sachen gefüllt, die mich einfach überhaupt nicht interessieren.
Interaktion.
Kann die nicht äh entfernen und äh all diese ganzen Sachen.
Ja, das ist das ist für also Usability ist hier echt irgendwie nicht groß geschrieben. Es gibt also eine schöne Facebook-Folge, äh Facebook sage ich schon. South Park, äh zero of Friends oder.
Die ist ganz toll.
Dass das eigentlich mit abgehandelt. Ähm ja, ich habe aber Angst, dass äh noch ist Facebook ja größer als Lokbuchnetz Politik und ich habe Angst, dass wir da vielleicht nicht äh.
Nicht mithalten können mit dem Wachstum.
Nee, mit den mit den Wachstumsanforderungen unserer Aktionäre, äh ne, also da muss,
Vielleicht ein bisschen was Threema kaufen oder so.
Wir sollten jetzt mehr auf den Shareholder-Value achten oder wie?
Ja, vielleicht. Ähm, ich habe da ein äh etwas älteren Artikel äh gesehen, wo wo jemand.
Hat sich überhaupt jemals schon mal bei dir gemeldet und gesagt, ich möchte gerne.
Über Facebook mit Logbuch Netzpolitik interagieren, das macht.
Wir haben ja die Fragen ja nicht vorher, die schreiben dann eine eine äh DM. Man kann hier, warte, ich suche das mal.
Auf Facebook.
Ja. Äh man kann quasi.
Man kann darüber nach A Nachrichten, klar, natürlich unter Nachrichten, man kann Nachrichten schicken. Und äh wir haben.
Eine. Sie eine Nachricht.
Hier guck mal, weitermachen. Haben wir eine Nachricht bekommen.
Von der Hörerin weitermachen Linus heißt es da.
Das wollte ich jetzt so nicht sagen, aber klar, die die Hörer.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und eine eine inhaltliche Empfehlung äh.
Haben wir hier irgendwas mit der Kacka Community? Ach ja.
Ah, du weißt, du weißt, wenn wenn wir, wenn wir anfangen so Kussmund irgendwie äh äh Selfies auf Facebook zu posten, dann ist vorbei mit uns, ne?
Oder mit Facebook, das wird's dann, ich meine.
Ja
Es ist äh ich, was willst du da sagen? Also äh den Artikel, den ich hier fand, der war, der hat dann sich mal so ein bisschen.
Also ich finde.
Hat sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, was diese mehr oder weniger von Facebook öffentlich bekanntgegebene Regel, dass sie anstreben, dass eine Seite im Schnitt zehn bis zwanzig Prozent.
Ihrer Fans, ihrer Follower erreicht. Ja, also das ist, nee, ein bis zwei Prozent.
Das ist also der, den Facebook da verfolgt. Und was hier jemand kritisiert, ist, dass er sagt, ja, niemand hat was dagegen, wenn Facebook, was weiß ich, Coca-Cola und äh McDonald's und und Apple Drosselt quasi,
aber für ähm für irgendwie Non-Profits und Aktivisten und so ist das natürlich,
sehr äh sehr übel, wenn ähm wenn da eben quasi,
Kommunikation und Reichweite beschnitten werden und gegen Geld wiedergegeben werden. Also sich dieses gesamte dieses gesamte Geschäftsmodell ist mir einfach zu wider. Ähm,
Und es ist unbegreift. Also ich glaube, ich habe jetzt auch irgendwo gelesen, jetzt wachsen schon wieder Kinder nach, die Facebook uncool finden. Also es besteht Hoffnung.
Nächste Generation. Ja.
Also so die die nächste Generation rebelliert gegen ihre lahmen Eltern, die auf Facebook rumgammeln,
und wollen was cooleres, Logbuch Netzpolitik zum Beispiel. Ich finde, wir könnten da durchaus einfach auch jetzt mal die Konfrontation suchen und uns da als als konkreter,
Gegen als konkretes Alternativangebot,
positionieren, weil ich sage mal, eine unstrukturierte Timeline, in der Leute kommunizieren und unter nicht Notify werden und eventuell die Hälfte der Antworten nicht gesehen wird, das haben wir bei uns in der Kommentarspalte eigentlich auch.
Läuft's. Also.
Das Ding ist, ich müsste das eigentlich zumachen jetzt, weil die, weil die
die die KPIs nicht stimmen. Wir wurden, wir haben die Ziele nicht erreicht, aber Synapsenkitzler hat gesagt, das kostet zwei neunundneunzig und bisher konnte ich das nicht verifizieren, ob das stimmt oder nicht, weil ich den Knopf nicht finde, wo man das zumacht.
Ich glaube aber.
Ich würde sagen, wir wir lassen das einfach. Wir lassen das da einfach so leichenhaft ähm vor sich hinzulegen, weil weißer Geier, vielleicht passiert da ja nochmal was.
Vielleicht ist Facebook ja das nächste große Ding.
Das könnte sein. Ich höre immer häufiger davon. Ja. Ja. Wir sind überheblich, sehr, ist klar. Weiß ich nicht. Doch, sind da. Ähm bisschen.
Ich habe auch schon öfter davon gehört. Weiß ich nicht. Ähm ein bisschen, ja. Macht ihr mal mit eurem Facebook, Hauptsache, ihr hört dabei, Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Genau. Schöner Facebook mit Doktor Netzpolitik.
Ihr könnt uns ja kann man auf Facebook Guthaben verschenken? Weiß ich nicht. Also bei allem anderen, wo man Geld ausgeben kann, kann man das.
Kann man da überhaupt Guthaben haben? Also ich meine, Geld geben doch da nur.
Wäre doch geil, du stehst irgendwie im Supermarkt an der Kasse und dann hast du ja so Google Play, App Store, Apple, ähm Amazon-Gutschein und so kannst du alles an der Kasse kaufen und dann so Facebook Guthaben,
hundert Likes.
Jetzt lass sie noch.
Ich habe nur Ideen.
Ja, ja, das war sehr schnell auch äh einen überholt, ne.
Gestern habe ich einen sehr sehr schönes Gespräch gehabt, da das wollte ich jetzt so kurz hier wiedergeben, weil wir hatten die Idee zuerst.
Da kam die Frage auf, warum eigentlich Zeitung bisher noch nicht,
biegt explizite Kategorie Terror haben. So, Schatz, gibst du mir mal den Terrorteil? Das wäre eigentlich.
Das wäre eigentlich so, ne, ich meine, du hast den Sportteil, Wirtschaft. So, ne? Und es ist, ich meine, das ist eigentlich witzig, dass sie das, dass sie dafür noch nicht einen eigenen Teil haben.
Das ist in der Tat. Genau, das ist geil.
Es wäre auch für die Leser und Leserinnen gut, weil du dann ja.
Sport, Terror.
Ne, dann kannst du auch sagen, dann weißt du auch, okay, möchtest du das jetzt lesen oder nicht, ne? Und das wäre eigentlich gut.
Wie wär's denn mal mit Inhalt?
Content ist Overrated, aber wir machen's, wir machen's trotzdem. Wir wir haben nämlich hier, es gibt wieder was Schönes ohne Inhalt. Nee. Nein.
Sind wir schon beim Terrorteil? Nein. Der Urteil kommt später. Jetzt kommt erstmal oder was? Nee, Deutschland.
Schatz, reichst du mir mal den Terrorteil?
Was haben wir denn da? Was ist denn sozusagen das erste Thema? In welcher Kategorie geht denn das erste Thema? Ähm welchen welchen Zeitungsteilung müssen wir jetzt äh.
Ich weiß gar nicht, das ist, glaube ich, noch so ähm.
Unklar, also vermischt ist sozusagen die Rückseite, aus aller Welt.
Ja, also im Elvis Huxley-Teil, würde ich sagen. Brave News.
Na gut. Brave News. Brave Newhar. Ja.
Ähm wir müssen ja nur mal also.
Hatten wir ja schon ein paar Mal.
Ist ja bekannt. So im Juli zweitausend.
So äh nimmst du ja die neuen über Facebook gewonnenen Hörer nicht mit, ne. Die ist ja bekannt, was ist denn das für eine Aussage, ne?
Ist wenn ihr eine Nachricht über Facebook schreibt und die dann bei Facebook ist.
Und das aber in Amerika und ihr unterwegs alle äh rechtlichen Ansprüche nach der europäischen Recht letztendlich verloren habt. Das ist Safe Haber. Und ähm.
Beziehungsweise das war.
Das war Safehaber, genau. Und dieses Safehaber gibt es, gab es, gibt es seit Juli zweitausend, wo nämlich die EU-Kommission gesagt hat, dass die USA,
EU-Bürgern einen angemessenen Datenschutz gewährleisten.
Per Aklamation.
Wenn sich die Firmen bestimmten Regeln unterwerfen, diese Regeln äh aber ob sie die jetzt einhalten oder nicht, wird der jetzt nicht besonders weiter ähm,
äh geprüft oder festgestellt, ja? So bis bis Herbst zweitausendfünfzehn gab es fünfeinhalbtausend Unternehmen, die sich unter diesem Safehaberabkommen registriert haben,
und und quasi von den von dem von der von dem kurzen Weg äh in den USA-Daten von Europäern vorzuhalten, ohne,
Als das Unternehmen einem rechtlichen Risiko ausgesetzt zu sein und wie gesagt,
die Unternehmen sich an die EU-Regeln halten oder nicht, äh wurde das wird nicht überprüft. Und,
In den USA galt aber, dass sie, dass die Unternehmen im,
dass das US-Behörden im Interesse der nationalen Sicherheit jederzeit auf die Daten dieser Unternehmen zugreifen können,
und gegen diese gegen diesen Zugriff harten EU-Bürger keinerlei Handhabe. Also war auch kein Datenschutz gewährleistet.
Mit dieser Argumentation hat dann der Max eine Klage gegen Facebook angestrengt, in der er gesagt hat, ihr,
Verletzt den EU-Datenschutz und damit meine Rechte als Nutzer, die mir zustehen,
Und ähm das möchte ich nicht. Das soll sich ändern.
Und da gab es am sechsten Oktober dann das das Urteil ähm.
Wo gesagt wurde, ja, die NSA verletzt die Grundrechte der europäischen Bürger, indem sie auf diese Daten zugreift.
Ähm und es gibt,
Keine rechtliche Möglichkeit, sich dagegen zu wehren. Insofern äh widerspricht das auch den den sonstigen Datenschutz,
Vorgaben, die wir hier haben. Und hat gesagt, okay, bis innerhalb von drei Monaten, nämlich bis zum,
Äh sechsten Januar oder so müsst ihr oder sechster Februar wäre jetzt wahrscheinlich, nee, bis sechster Januar, braucht ihr eine neue Einigung, ja? Und,
Also ne, Problem eins, Massenüberwachung sowieso. Problem zwei, es gibt keine Möglichkeit, dagegen zu klagen. So und dann gab es eine,
Eine Gruppe, die sich zusammensetzte, ähm wird aus Vertretern des äh des äh EU-Parlaments
oder der Vertretern der EU, unter anderem der Justizkommissarin Vera Yova und eben US-Vertretern. Die sollten dann eben ein neues Safe haben, eine neue Safehaber-Regelung ähm,
aus Kaspern,
die auf diese beiden Kritikpunkte eingeht. Und die haben jetzt am Dienstagmorgen feierlich verkündet, dass sie eine Einigung erlangt haben.
Die aber noch nicht verschriftlicht ist.
Aber es ist alles okay.
Genau, ist alles, ist alles super, wir können weitermachen,
im Moment befegen die sich jetzt also mit diesem Datenaustausch in so 'ner rechtlichen Grauzone, weil eigentlich darf es jetzt keinen mehr geben. Ja, also die haben offenbar auch diese Verhandlungen teilweise wohl strategisch.
Bis an diesen Punkt und über diesen Punkt hinausgeführt und nun äh feierlich bekannt gegeben, dass es ein Ombuz Mann im Statypartment geben wird,
der ähm äh Beschwerden der Europäer, der Europäischen Bürger, entgegennehmen kann und die Zusicherungen der US-Unternehmen,
Die Zusicherung von US-Seite, dass nicht an Discriminutory äh überwacht wird, also,
Überwachung will man offenbar Diskriminierung, ja, man möchte also nicht alle überwachen. Das ist quasi das äh das das bedeutet.
Also du möchtest diskriminiert, sondern also das heißt, du musst nach irgendeinem Merkmal.
Trennen von überwacht in nicht überwacht, dann ist das in Ordnung. Wenn du das nicht machst, ist es Massenüberwachung, ja? Ähm und diese Zusicherung, dass die Unternehmen das machen, soll dieser Mann auch prüfen.
Und zwar jährlich. Genau. Ähm so, das ist natürlich so, das heißt, wir setzen jetzt hier einen ein,
der wird das prüfen und euch das zusichern. Und wenn ihr Beschwerden habt, dann prüft ihr die auch.
Ja, der unterliegt aber natürlich trotzdem dem Statypartner und der der Arbeitgeber ist das State Department und die Interessen gelten den USA, das ist also keine,
Keine unabhängige Person, die hat auch äh in ihrer es ist ja noch nicht ausformuliert, aber die hat oft,
anscheinend auch keine nennenswerten Sanktionsmöglichkeiten. Ja, das also das ist äh juristisch äh ein natürlich wieder ein absoluter Scherz, ja. Ähm,
weil es eben keine unabhängige Stelle ist, weil es keine Vereinbarung ist und weil es weil sich letztendlich nicht wirklich etwas ändert, so ähm es gibt im Prinzip nur,
Jetzt eine Adresse, an wen du dich wenden kannst,
damit die, damit du nicht direkt irgendwie äh vor einem äh vor einem europäischen Gericht äh endest oder dich von Irland irgendwie durchklagest, wie das gemacht hat, sondern jetzt halt laut Vereinbarung, dich erst mal bei den USA melden musst. Ja?
Also die Kommission hat sozusagen das das Thema jetzt so.
Ja, genau, aber ist eigentlich noch ist ja noch viel, viel, also es bleibt ja noch noch lustiger, denn.
Das Kernproblem ist ja nun mal, dass es diese Massenüberwachung überhaupt gibt und was sie uns jetzt, was sie jetzt was die USA jetzt angeboten haben, ist ja wir machen das nicht mehr und es gibt einen Umutsmann, an den ihr euch wenden könnt,
Was sie aber nicht machen, ist ihre äh lokalen Gesetze ändern, nämlich zum Beispiel den äh Pfeiser Foren,
Informations ich weiß nicht genau wofür das I steht International.
Ähm Foren Intelligence Survayance Act.
Also der, der, der, das Gesetz zur,
Spionage und Informationssammlung über über äh andere Länder. Ähm da ist eben in Sexion siebenhundertzwei steht ja drin, dass dass die USA,
äh je alle ausländischen Daten erfassen und verwerten dürfen und ähm,
nicht US-Bürger ähm und nicht US-Unternehmen keinerlei Schutzrechte genießen. Und das ändern sie nicht,
Das wäre also eine, das wäre jetzt eine Konsequenz, eine glaubwürdige Konsequenz gewesen, dass sich die Zusicherung der US-Seite auch in ihrem, ihren eigenen nationalen Gesetzen wiederspiegeln will. Das machen wir nicht.
Ähm.
Das heißt, es gibt keine keine juristisch verbindlichen Verbesserung und stattdessen gibt es jetzt ein Ombuzman, der äh Boote für die gleichen Botschaften wird, die es schon vorher gab. Ähm,
Und da das jetzt überhaupt von einer Einigung sprechen, äh,
Ist zurückzuführen auf ein paar Briefe von James Klepper. Und das finde ich sehr äh interessant, Patrick, ähm Beuth von äh Zeit Online hat. Ähm,
sehr mutig ihn schon im Titel seines Artikels als einen Lügner bezeichnet, was äh man darf, weil er,
im Congress über die US-Massenüberwachung nachweislich gelogen hat. Ja, also das ist ein dieser US-Geheimdienstkoordinator James Klapper, ist ein dokumentierter Lügner,
ja? Und von dem auf dessen.
Bild und in Bild und Ton dokumentiert in seinen Reaktionen vor dem Kongresssenat.
Genau. Dann gibt es eine gibt es äh auf die Intercept noch einige Einschätzungen von den U von den EU Gruppen, also irgendwie und Edry und so, die ähm,
Diskussionen schildern als hauptsächlich darüber, ob ob das jetzt äh das
Urteil antiamerikanisch war
und ob die äh EU die die Demokratie der USA äh zurückweisen wolle, ähm was natürlich überhaupt nicht äh Thema dieser Sache ist, ja. Ich meine, das ist ein ein klares
Gerichtsurteil an, anhand von juristischen Fakten. Und ähm jetzt wird hier
Man könnte jetzt im Prinzip sagen, was wir jetzt da bekommen. Als Ergebnis ist so ein No-Spy-Abkommen, ne? Äh wo irgendwie so drinsteht, so Idee, wir machen das nicht,
Wenn doch, äh könnt ihr uns einen Brief schreiben, hier ist eine Adresse, ne? Aber ohne jegliche rechtliche Bindung.
Ja, die Diskussion ist jetzt beendet und das äh.
Es gibt noch eine zweite Sache, auf die sie sich stützen, außer dieser dieser Briefe von Klepper. Und das ist, es gibt quasi ein nennt er sich.
Ein Gesetzesentwurf, der schon durchs Haus ist, aber noch nicht durch den Sammet. Ähm und dieser würde klagen von EU-Bürgern,
Bei Datenschutzverletzungen theoretisch erlauben, ermöglichen, also da gibt es dann einen Weg.
Weil das ist ja sozusagen auch äh Kernpunkt dieser ganzen Auseinandersetzung.
Genau, das war der der zweite wichtige Punkt.
Dass man einfach nicht selber klagen kann, wie man das in Europa eben kann und da geht's halt nicht, weil das sowieso erstmal nur US-Bürgern äh vorbehalten ist, dort Klage zu erheben und es auch durch.
So und äh.
Nicht möglich gemacht wird.
Dieser der soll das ermöglichen,
Sagt Allah so, wenn jetzt aber die die Behörde gegen die du ähm klagst als Europäer,
sich auf ein Privileg beruft, eine Ausnahme oder eine Einschränkung, dann kann diese Behörde,
den zuständigen Richter oder die Richterin zwingen, ihre Eingabe zu diesem Thema geheim zu halten,
und sogar ohne Information des Klägers zu prüfen. Das heißt, du gehst hin und sagst hallo, äh die verletzen meine ähm Rechte.
Ja? Und dann geht diese Behörde, also im Zweifelsfall die NSA zu dem Richter und sagt,
So, äh du bist gezwungen, äh geheim zu halten, warum was wir dazu sagen und.
Prüfung, die du jetzt durchführst, darüber über deren Ergebnis darfst du dem klagenden Partei auch keine Auskunft geben.
Und dann weißt du diese Klage bitte ab. Das heißt, du du erfährst dann, also,
das wahrscheinliche Ergebnis ist, du klagst und deine Klage wird ohne Begründung abgewiesen, weil die Begründung für die Abweisung deiner Klage geheim ist.
Ist geil, oder? Es ist wirklich gut. Also.
Ist geil, oder? Es ist wirklich gut. Also du du das heißt, du du hast dokumentiert, du du bringst was weiß ich, beweise oder sowas vor,
reißen eine Klage ein und dann kriegst du von dem Gericht wird dir gesagt, wir müssen ihre Klage äh leider abweisen. Begründung können wir leider nicht sagen.
Kafka noch leben würde, der würde jetzt Copyright Klage erheben.
Das ist wirklich äh,
Insofern also dieser ist also auch wirklich ein ein Meisterwerk, ein Meisterwerk.
Gerichtliche Schadensbegrenzung.
Das ist wirklich großartig, ja. Ähm.
Ja, ähm es gibt dazu für,
wir haben das Thema jetzt grob umrissen, das Schlachtfeld, es gibt ähm natürlich zu empfehlen, den Vortrag von Max äh Schremp auf dem zweiunddreißig C drei
ähm zu dieser Safehaber-Thematik ähm ebenfalls von Max äh jetzt eine eine Stellungnahme zu diesem US,
So soll ja äh dieser äh Brave Newhaber heißen.
Ein Logo haben sie schon.
Genau, ein Logo haben sie schon. Das ist geil. Die haben noch keinen Text, aber ein Logo. Wir sind uns einig, wir müssen das nur noch runterschreiben. Das, so mache ich demnächst auch meine Verträge. Wir sind uns einig, ich schreibe nur noch worüber.
Schild. Klingt so ein bisschen wie so ein Antivirus-Paket, ne? Aber was die einem so auf die Platte installieren, weiß man ja auch teilweise. Also, weißt du, nicht selten dann auch etwas zu Hause.
Witz, dass wir sind uns einig.
Ja, Peter Scharr hat sich da ja auch schon äh sehr skeptisch äh geäußert,
Unter anderem auch ähm vorgestern auf dem nitzpolitischen Abend der. Da war ja äh vor Ort.
Ist auch online, äh bei Heise noch einen Kommentar zu finden,
Ich denke, das ist jetzt hier noch nicht äh das letzte Wort in dieser ganzen Debatte.
Es ist einfach nur wieder ein äh ein weiteres Kapitel im in diesem Drama, was ich wirklich fragt. Na ja.
Amerikaner, die verstehen aber auch wahrscheinlich Europa irgendwie gar nicht, habe ich sie denn einnehmen.
Nee, das ist ja auch, also ich meine, das ist klar, anti-amerikanisch.
Was da abgeht.
Was da abgeht. Das ist eindeutig nicht in deren Interesse. Also es ist antiamerikanisch.
Tja, und Europa hat eher so Skepsis, ob da irgendwie ja, ob da überhaupt alles so nach rechten Dingen läuft, ne.
Ich meine, nicht, dass wir keine Skepsis hätten, ob bei uns alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht, aber ist das schon nochmal so ein kleiner Bruch, der großen Graben stattfindet auf dem Weg nach Westen.
Ciao. Wir werden das äh beobachten, da wird's sicherlich in den nächsten Tagen und Wochen noch mehr zu berichtigen. Äh ja, zu berichtigen und zu.
Auf jeden Fall.
Geben, ist noch einiges zu berichtigen geben.
Ja
So, dann hatten wir Ende November ähm auch darüber berichtet, dass der äh Bundesgerichtshof im Rahmen von zwei Verfahren, wo,
ähm einmal der der Verband der Tonträgerhersteller und einmal die GEMA äh sich angestrengt hatten, äh Seiten zu sperren auf den illegale Downloads äh bereitgestellt würden. So und der,
Diese Klagen sind beide daran gescheitert, dass der BGH meinte, ja, die klagenden hätten keine ausreichenden, zumutbaren Anstrengungen unternommen.
Und nannte da nannte diese zumutbaren Anstrengungen aus, die hätten eine
beauftragen können zur Ermittlung der Täter, äh ein Unternehmen einschalten können, dass Ermittlungen im Zusammenhang mit rechtswidrigen Angeboten im Internet durchführt
oder staatliche Ermittlungsbehörden einschalten können und wenn all das nicht.
Zu den Tätern führt, dann könne eine Websperre als Ultima Ratio in Betracht kommen. Das war der Teil des Urteils, der bisher äh quasi bekannt war.
Den wir ja auch schon.
Den wir auch diskutiert hatten. Und jetzt ähm,
Und wie gesagt, interessant, die haben die mit dieser Begründung auch diese beiden Verfahren verloren. Ähm.
Aber in der Urteilsbegründung, die jetzt ähm vorliegt,
Stellt der Bundesgerichtshof sehr eindeutig fest, dass eben Netzsperren grundsätzlich durchsetzbar sind.
Und ähm,
da diese Urteilsbegründung ist natürlich jetzt sehr spannend, weil auf dieser Begründung sich in Zukunft halt netzsperren in Deutschland äh.
Zeigen werden oder hoffentlich eben nicht. So, was was haben sie äh was haben sie geurteilt?
Ähm sie sagen erstmal keine Haftung oder Verantwortung des Providers, ne, also der Provider,
äh weder unter als Täter noch unter dem Aspekt der Störerhaftung rechtlich für diese Inhalte verantwortlich. Also, die Telekom betreibt einen von der Rechtsordnung gebilligtes,
und gesellschaftlich erwünschtes Geschäftsmodell, nämlich Internet den Leuten zu geben. Und.
Dieses sei als solches nicht in besonderer Weise ähm dazu geeignet, die Gefahr von Urheberrechtsverletzungen zu schaffen. Also nur, dass du den Leuten Internetzugang gibst, äh ist nicht unbedingt jetzt das,
Das Hauptziel der der ähm dass das diese dann eben dann mit Urheberrechtsverletzungen begehen,
Deshalb darfst du der Telekom auch keine
Kontrollmaßnahmen auferlegen oder den Providern keine Kontrollmaßnahmen auferlegen, die das Geschäftsmodell gewirtschaftlich gefährden oder die die das Geschäftsmodell Internetzugang anbieten, unverhältnismäßig erschweren.
Das sagte, sagen wir erstmal grundsätzlich so. Und jetzt kommen sie zu den Argumenten pro und gegen Netzsperren, die von den ähm.
Die die, sage ich mal, von den Gegnern, von Netzsperren äh hervorgebracht werden. Erstens, die Effektivität, also das Argument, Netzsperren können umgangen werden.
Funktionieren,
Also nichts sind keine sinnvolle Methode zum zum nicht zugänglich machen von Inhalten. Dieser Argumentation hatte sich das Oberlandesgerichts Köln,
angeschlossen und in seiner Urteilsbegründung die Unwirksamkeit von Netz von von DNS oder IP Sperren als Ablehnungsgrund,
genannt. Der Bundesgerichtshof sagt, na ja, okay, man kann diese Sperren umgehen. Die Mehrzahl der Nutzer kann es aber nicht,
Also sind äh ist das jetzt nicht ein grundsätzlich nicht probates Mittel. Funktioniert ja bei den meisten.
Die meisten gehen am Flatterband vorbei sozusagen.
Ja, also ich meine, dass.
Meisten lassen sich vom Flatterband aufhalten so.
Ich kann mich dem sogar im Prinzip.
Ja, das ist äh nachvollziehbar.
Argumentation folgen. Du hast viele Dinge, die Sachen unmöglich machen oder die Sachen verhindern sollen, die nicht einhundert Prozent greifen, ja? Wir schließen auch unsere Türen ab mit irgendwelchen acht Euro.
Sag es mein Lieblingssatz. Hundertprozentige Sicherheit kann es nicht geben.
Sie sagen also, okay, das das technische Argument, dass diese Maßnahme umgangen werden kann, ist kein ausreichendes, um die Maßnahme grundsätzlich nicht zuzulassen.
Das zweite Argument, Overblocking, ja, das zielt ja auf den gesellschaftlichen Schaden, äh,
Solcher Netzsperren, die über die intendierten Effekt des des Nichtmehr zugänglich Machens dieser Angebote hinausgehen ab.
Und da sagen sie, dass,
Problem ist, wenn wir Overblocking als Argument gelten lassen, dann können sich die Anbieter eines auf Rechtsverletzungen angelegten Geschäftsmodells,
hinter wenigen legalen Angeboten verstecken. Ja, also du sagst, keine Ahnung, du machst ein Forum auf,
wird zu ein Prozent über äh Politik diskutiert und neunundneunzig Prozent äh Falschharing betrieben, dann kannst du jetzt nicht sagen, dass äh die die ein Prozent kollateralschaden ähm.
Ein ähm quasi Overblocking wären. Oder,
was ja noch viel übler ist. Du gehst oder was jetzt immer noch final liegender wäre, du gehst mit deinem rechte verletzenden Angebot auf irgendwie so ein oder so oder auf irgendeine Unterdomain und machst sorgst so dafür, dass du nicht geblockt werden,
kannst, ja?
Das machen übrigens das ganz interessant ist, scheint eine der besten Möglichkeiten zu sein, um die chinesische Zensurinfrastruktur zu umgehen,
Sachen in die Amazon Cloud zu legen, weil da liegt so viel und die Amazon Cloud ist so fluide
wo sie quasi diese Inhalte haben, dass äh die chinesische Firewall da nicht sinnvoll hinterher kommt. Diese Inhalte zu sperren, vor allem, wenn sie dann über HTTPS zugegriffen werden und so, ja, das heißt, da äh,
scheint eben eine der Möglichkeiten zu sein für chinesische Disidenten der Zensur zu umgehen, die Sachen ausgerechnet bei Amazon hinzulegen, weil da eben die technischen.
Aber nicht mehr in Deutschland. Das heißt, bei uns äh äh kommt dann alles unter die Räder, was bei Amazon irgendwie gehostet ist. Genau.
Genau, da da wäre eben das Argument, ja okay, dann sperrst halt Amazon, so die die rechte Verletzer dürfen sich ja nicht quasi hinter legal ein legales Schutzschild.
Und da das finde ich jetzt schon mal eine eine ziemlich gewagte These, weil äh sicherlich haben wir bisher Overblocking immer noch so unter diesem Aspekt
gesehen mit, na ja, da ist so der Server, aber da sind ja noch neun andere drauf. Aber das im Prinzip diese äh IP oder DNS-Sperren äh im Prinzip dazu führen könnten
Ja, deshalb nur noch so supergenerische äh Einträge äh gesperrt werden, die sich vielleicht auch am laufenden Meter ändern,
am laufenden Meter von woanders kommt und sich einfach über dieses Mittel von von DNS oder IP-Sperben überhaupt nicht mehr fangen lässt, weil er im Prinzip die ganze Zeit,
und sich am laufenden Meter neu durchpflügt, dass man da gar nicht hinterher kommen kann,
Und was ist dann? Ja, ich meine, da ist das ist dann vor allem nicht nur ein Overblocking, sondern das ist dann eben auch ein Fehlblocking. Das heißt, da wird einmal eine Sperre ausgesprochen, die eine Woche später was ganz anderes trifft.
Also das, das, das äh ist schon noch ein problematisches äh problematischer Aspekt, den sieht aber das BGH hier offensichtlich nicht.
Also der der BGH schließt und sagt, okay, es liegt auf der Hand, dass eine Sperrung nicht nur dann zulässig sein kann, wenn ausschließlich rechtswidrige Informationen auf der Webseite bereitgehalten werden.
Ja? Ähm dann gab es hatte wohl hatten die,
beklagten, das Argument angebracht, dass das Fernmeldegeheimnis verletzt würde,
wenn quasi in die Kommunikation eingegriffen wird.
Weil du ja nicht sperren kannst ohne eine Form von Überwachungs quasi zu machen, was was da passiert. Äh da haben sie aber gesagt, nee,
Ähm äh,
Artikel zehn, Absatz eins Grundgesetz umfasst, also das Fernmeldegeheimnis umfasst nur den nichtöffentlichen Austausch konkreter Kommunikationsteilnehmer.
Eine an die Allgemeinheit gerichtet Kommunikation fällt nicht unter das Fernmeldegeheimnis. Das ist auch jetzt irgendwie ähm,
Eine gewagte These, ähm weil sie mir relativ schnell eben auch an die Allgemeinheit gerichtete Infrastrukturen,
einfallen, die unter das, bei denen das Fernmeldegeheimnis gilt. Ja, also
ein E-Mail Provider, der ein Website eine Webseite bereithält, über die man die E-Mail lesen kann, ja? Aber ich glaube, dass meinen Sie hier dann auch nicht als ein Andi Allgemeinheit gerichtetes Angebot, sondern Ihnen geht es hier darum, dass der bemängelte,
digitale Download der Allgemeinheit zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Ohne Zugangs, ohne Login oder sonst was Beschränkungen, deswegen nicht unter das Fernmeldegeheimnis fehlt. Dann gibt's einen weiteren interessanten Aspekt.
Dass sie in diesem Urteil erstmalig in Deutschland höchstrichterlich IP-Adressen als Personenbezogene Daten interpretieren. Das ist ein jahrelanger äh Streit.
Und ähm sie sagen, wenn im Rahmen,
Errichtens dieser Sperren. Personenbezogene Daten in Form von IP-Adressen erfasst werden, ist das in Ordnung. Denn eine Nutzung von IP-Adressen unterliege den Vorschriften des Telekommunikationsgesetzes,
und nach Telekommunikationsgesetz dürfen Verkehrsdaten nur zu Zwecken erhoben werden, die das herstellen und aufrechterhalten einer Kommunikationsverbindung betreffen.
Ich verstehe den Satz nicht so ganz,
Aber äh der entscheidende Punkt ist also eher sie sagen, okay das da IP-Adressen mit beschäftigt werden, ist erstmal okay, weil zum Herstellen der Funktion dürfen Verkehrsdaten genutzt werden,
Gleichzeitig sagen sie aber eben, IP-Adressen sind äh personenbezogene Daten. Ähm,
die unterfallen personenbezogene Daten, unterfallen Paragraph drei Absatz eins des Bundesdatenschutzgesetzes, weil der Zugangsprovider ein Bezug zwischen den IP-Adressen und der Person des Nutzers herstellen kann.
Ähm auch natürlich jetzt spannend, die der,
Der Zusammenhang kann ja natürlich eigentlich nicht hergestellt werden, weil die IP-Adresse für den Anschlussinhaber ist. Also werden wir sehen, ob's da noch weitere Urteile gibt.
Body ist sie sagen Overblock ist kein Argument gegen netsperren, von dem sie überzeugt werden
Umgehbarkeit ist kein Argument gegen Netzsperren, von dem sie überzeugt werden. Fernmeldegeheimnis ist keine Argument gegen netzsperren und die die Verwendung personenbezogener Daten
ebenfalls nicht alle vier Argumente überzeugen sie nicht. Sie sagen aber, die äh Netzsperre muss,
kann nicht verargumentiert werden als eine Verpflichtung des Providers, den man irgendeiner Form der äh der Täter schafft oder der.
Der Störerhaftung ähm zuschreiben könnte, sondern als Ultima Ratio,
könnte diese in Betracht kommen, wenn man alles andere versucht hat, um der Täter habhaft zu werden. Ähm und sie an der Bereitstellung dieses Angebotes zu hindern.
So das Urteil des Bundesgerichtshofes.
Nicht so schön.
Nicht so schön, ja. Das haben wir aber auch ja. Äh wussten wir auch im November schon. Das ist äh nicht schön.
Und jetzt? Keine Ahnung. Nehmen wir das zur Kenntnis.
Nehmen wir zur Kenntnis und äh müssen uns überlegen, diese Argumente äh also dieser wenn der BGH diese Ansicht vertritt, dann ist das eben leider so, ne.
In das Verfassungsgericht äh kommt dann nochmal zu anderen Schlüssen.
Da weiß ich nicht genau, wie da die ähm die Zuständigkeiten in diesem Fall sind, weil ich nicht mehr genau erinnere, auf welcher Basis da äh.
Ja gut, da müsste natürlich eine entsprechende Klage angestrengt werden, die das jetzt unmittelbar äh betrifft. In dem.
Könnte aber dann erst sein, wenn sage ich mal die erste Sperre irgendwo verhängt würde.
Genau und irgendjemand oder oder sich jemand schon mal so äh theoretisch in Zukunft betroffen sieht davon. Könnte man ja auch klagen, also geht ja auch schon vorher.
Dummerweise als kann man schon machen, aber es wäre natürlich jetzt, sage ich mal, für so einen,
jemanden, der sich tatsächlich betroffen zieht von so Netzsperren, äh die suchen ja in der Regel jetzt nicht das Licht der Öffentlichkeit oder der Gerichtsseele, ja, also.
Drauf an, wer als nächstes so äh gesperrt wird, ne. Ich meine, wenn da jetzt diese AdBlocker-Industrie äh konkret,
Zum Beispiel angegangen werden würde, die sind ja schon ausreichend wirtschaftlich aufgestellt. Weiß nicht, ob das das betrifft.
Du meinst das net sperren gegen die Download-Seiten von AdBlockern? Das wäre geil. Ähm blocken.
Ja oder den den Betriebser sozusagen, ja.
Irgendwann haben wir das ganze Internet weggeblockt, das wäre vielleicht am Ende besser fürs alle.
Einfach auch weg mit dem Netz.
Blocken, block, block, block.
Ja, dann können wir ja unser Projekt auch eigentlich einstellen.
Dann werden wir auch das Problem der Überwachung des Internets direkt los. Ähm das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium,
hat seinen ähm,
seinen Jahresbericht herausgegeben, über die Fernmelde, über die Verletzungen des Fernmeldegeheimnisses ähm,
im Jahre zweitausendfünfzehn. Und äh das,
den BND und der BND hat ja diese hat quasi sein Datenschleppnetz und da drin sind,
fünfundzwanzigtausendzweihundertundneun Telekommunikationsverkehre hängen geblieben. Zweitausenddreizehn waren es noch fünfzehntausend. Das heißt, wir haben eine sehr signifikante Zunahme.
Im Jahr zweitausendvierzehn,
Das also der Bericht, wie gesagt, für zweitausendvierzehn, ihrem Schaufen, bei das gesamte Jahr zweitausendfünfzehn gebraucht, um die Daten zusammenzutragen und auszuwerten,
Das ist natürlich deshalb interessant, weil äh da ja dann quasi diese ganze Snow Geschichte losgehen. Ja, das heißt, währenddessen,
das alles debattiert wurde.
Nochmal richtig ab.
Ging's nochmal richtig rund. Ja. Ähm.
Was wurde da so überwacht?
Der Hauptselekt, der Haupt, also sie haben ja äh eine lange Reihe an an Suchbegriffen,
Und diese super Griffe sind in drei Gefahrenbereichen ähm sortiert. Der der größte daran ist der Sektor internationaler Terrorismus,
äh wo mit neunhundertsechzig Suchwörtern äh vierzehntausend und sechshundertundvier Verkehre hängengeblieben sind.
Hauptsächlich Verkehre aus dem Bereich Internet und E-Mail. Das waren zweitausenddreizehn nur neunhundertundsechs Verkehre. Also da haben wir eine äh Verfünfzehntausendfachung.
Internet und E-Mail.
Verfünfzehnfachung, Entschuldigung.
Also beides sozusagen, sowohl Internet als auch E-Mail.
Genau, beides, beide Arten von Musik und ähm.
Irgendwie eintausendunddreiundsiebzig Verbindungs- oder Standortdaten und dreizehntausenddreihundertneunundzwanzig SMS Nachrichten wurden gesammelt.
Von dieser ganzen großen Menge an Kommunikationsakten stuft der BND allerdings nur dreiundsechzig Kommunikationsakte als Nachrichtendienstlich relevant ein,
Ähm.
Dann haben sie der der zweite Bereich, ne, nach dem äh nach dem Terror ist, äh Proliforation und konventionelle Rüstung,
Da haben sie äh,
Im ersten Halbjahr, äh, zweitausendvierzehn mit elftausendsechshundertsiebzig Suchbegriffen gearbeitet, im zweiten Halbjahr aber nur noch mit zweitausendsiebenundachtzig Suchbegriffen,
ich weiß, ich glaube elftausendsechshundertsiebzig Suchbegriffe, das ist doch der, du wirst wahrscheinlich der Wortschatz eines durchschnittlichen Deutschen, oder?
Interessanter Vergleich.
Ganz ehrlich, ich wüsste, ich weiß nicht genau, was er guckt, was Wortschatz Pegida. Ach nee, der ist weniger. Äh Deutsch, hä?
Wortschatz.
Also Deutschland, die deutsche Standardsprache hat fünfundsiebzigtausend. Schon geil.
Okay, egal. Also, auf jeden Fall relativ viel und da konnten sie auf den größeren Teil auch verzichten. Ähm.
Damit haben sie dann ungefähr zehntausend Telekommunikationsverkehre äh festgehaftet,
Das sind weniger als sie ähm,
als sie äh zweitausenddreizehn hatten, da hatten sie nämlich irgendwie vierzehntausend. Und dann der dritte Bereich illegale äh Schleusung, der spielt keine vergleichbar große Rolle. Äh anhand von achtundzwanzig Suchbegriffen,
Wurden dort siebzehn Kommunikationsakte gefunden, von denen keiner als Basis für eine äh Meldung herangezogen wurde.
Dann wurden noch zehn Überwachungen im Fall durchgeführt, bei denen es sich um Entführung deutscher Staatsbürger im Ausland handelte.
Ähm also quasi da, dass sie dann sagen, so okay, wir müssen jetzt hier überwachen.
Im Allfall verstanden. Also im Weltall, man weiß ja da wo man beliebig.
Oh man, wo, ja, wenn du dahin entführt wirst, dann kann dir nur der WND helfen.
Keine Auskunft gibt's über die äh Erfassung von Routineverkehren und Beifang, äh die der BND an die NSA weitergibt, denn damit äh setzt sich ja
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss auseinander. Da wollten sie jetzt irgendwie nichts zu sagen. Tja.
So
Also
Interessant zu sehen, ne. Die haben sich da jetzt nicht durch die öffentlichen Debatten, die jetzt nicht nennenswert äh an ihre Arbeit hindern lassen. Äh so wünscht man sich das ja auch für eine effektive Organisation, dass sie halt auf Nachhaltigkeit ausgelegt ist
sich von so äh Stimmungsschwankungen der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung äh von ihrem Kerngeschäft nicht ablenken lässt.
Immer so schlecht redest du unsere Geheimdienste.
Das ist doch nicht schlecht geredet.
Die müssen sich die müssen sich halt auch fit halten für äh die Kriege der Zukunft. Ja und da gibt's immer wieder neue Gegner.
Bargeld.
Ja, Bargeld ist einfach mal gefährdet nicht auch täglich. Primär durch Abwesenheit, aber auch die Präsenz ist äh zunehmendem Maße in Verruf gekommen. Hat jetzt wer herausgefunden eigentlich.
Das ist natürlich eine alte Forderung.
Ja, aber wer hat sie wieder ausgegraben? Ach so.
Bundesfinanzministerium.
Es geht natürlich um Geldwäsche und das äh ist ja, sagen wir mal auch durchaus ein wichtiges Thema, weil natürlich,
Finanzströme, die frei laufen, auch eine ganze Menge äh Korruption ermöglichen und zwar nicht nur theoretisch, sondern auch ganz praktisch.
Natürlich vor allem auch auf einem,
Internationalen äh Level, aber auch innerhalb Deutschlands. Und natürlich ist es im Interesse eines Finanzministeriums konkret ein,
Einblick zu haben in die wirtschaftlichen Aktivitäten einzelner Teilnehmer und Organisationen,
um sicherzustellen, dass dort auch alles nach Recht und Gesetz abläuft. Weil der Staat will natürlich auch seine Steuern haben und vor allem will er natürlich auch ähm wie heißt es schön, das organisierte Verbrechen im,
haben, was ganz gut da drin ist. Geldsummen von A nach B zu schieben. Und.
Ja, man muss arbeiten,
muss man jetzt mal eine Lanze für das organisierte Verbrechen äh hier brechen, weil denen wird es also auch wirklich sehr schwer gemacht, ihre Einkünfte zu versteuern.
Ja, also da da wird das, da legt der Staat aber auch Steine in den Weg.
Ja, was denn für welche? Wollt ihr denn immer gleich mit einsperren wollen oder was?
Weil die hier direkt immer mit ihren anderen Gesetzen kommen, ja. Äh.
So und es ist natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht die Digitalisierung äh der Welt da auch ein äh Segen, alle äh Banktransaktionen laufen heutzutage digital ab oder zumindest der Großteil und,
Das lässt sich natürlich im Prinzip, so ist denn überhaupt Einblick in diese Datenströme äh gibt, ganz gut abgreifen und da gibt's ja auch,
seit Jahren schon gesteigerte Interesse, auch von den Geheimdiensten, Swift
also sozusagen das internationale Bankensystem wird gemonitort, wird äh entsprechend untersucht, aber dann bleibt ja noch das Problem des Bargelds. Davon äh gibt's ja so einiges, da sind äh einige Milliarden im Umlauf,
Keine Ahnung, was äh derzeit so das Bargeldvolumen in Deutschland insgesamt so ist. Ja und wenn natürlich viel bar bezahlt wird, bleiben da,
wenig ohne Weiteres nachvollziehbare Spuren. Und daraus resultiert so ein bisschen die Idee, man könne doch generell für Zahlungen,
Wirtschaftsverkehr eine Deckelung zu machen, dass man sozusagen sagt, alles was jetzt über fünftausend Euro geht.
Muss in irgendeiner Form per Überweisung, Banken gestützt äh stattfinden.
Stattfinden. Möchte also soll letztendlich,
Das ist ja der, der Punkt, am Ende Zahlungssysteme aus gutem Grund, für sage ich mal, für jetzt irgendwie Überweisungen und äh,
Solche Geschichten, Kreditkarten oder so, gewinnen ja ihre Sicherheit dadurch, dass sie vollständig überwacht sind.
Also ne, wenn ich mit meiner Kreditkarte etwas bezahle, kann ich davon ausgehen, dass dieser Zahlungsvorgang äh auf alle Zeit abgesichert und äh dokumentiert ist.
Und damit,
automatisch quittiert, ja? Du hast also quasi, du hast ja eine Abrechnung von deiner Bank, wo du sagen kannst, hier dieses Geld ist an diese Person gegangen. Das heißt, du hast im Prinzip diese ganze dieses ganze Belegwesen da drin, ne? Brauchst ja
letztendlich so ein Betrag gar nicht mehr quittieren zu lassen, weil du ja die die Überweisung an der Stelle hast,
Einschränkungen mögen eine Rolle spielen, aber du hast die Sicherheit des des der Finanztransaktionen der nicht bargeldgebundenen Finanztransaktionen rührt daher, dass sie,
vollständig erfasst sind, dokumentiert, nachvollziehbar,
und ähm dieser dieser Sicherheit möchten äh jetzt freundlicherweise äh so gut wie alle Geldflüsse ähm zuführen. Ähm.
Das Problem, auf der anderen Seite ist eben, dass diese,
Digital verwaltete Geld und die digital erfassten Finanzströme eben auch so wahrscheinlich das das,
eindringlichste Überwachungswerkzeug sind, äh was wir überhaupt haben über über die Handlungen von Personen. Ja, also reinzuschauen, was ähm.
Wie viel Geld hat die Person? Wo gibt die das aus? Ähm das ist schon noch mal eine Überwachungsinfrastruktur, über die über deren Implikation sich relativ wenig Gedanken gemacht wird.
Es gibt weiterhin ähm an anderer Stelle Bestrebungen, diese.
Sage ich mal, in in Gewerben, die äh die Schwarzgeld nah sind oder die gerne äh zum,
zur Geldwäsche genutzt werden ähm oder auch in äh stark Bargeldbasierten Gewerben, wo wiederum äh der die Möglichkeiten der Steuerhinterziehung relativ groß sind.
Was würdet ihr als erstes einfallen?
Ja, nimmst du nimmst du nimmst du was, was viel Geld mit kleinen Beträgen umsetzt? Ähm Kneipen und Restaurants.
Dass er das naheliegende, sage ich mal, jetzt könnte man ja theoretisch sagen, man macht eine Kneipe auf, hm, man stellt sich da irgendwie so und so viel Kästen Bier rein äh und,
ne, dann ähm.
Nimmt man am Ende die Hälfte von der Kasse und legt die aufs Konto und die andere Hälfte liegt man unters Kopfkissen und das Geld hat nie jemand gesehen. Äh deswegen gehen dann die oder gehen die Finanzämter ja auch davon aus und sagen, na ja, uns interessiert überhaupt gar nicht, was du in der Kasse hattest
gucken, was du eingekauft hast, ja? Also wenn du jetzt als Kneipe hingehst und du hast äh, kaufst zehn Kisten Bier, dann.
Wird quasi bei der Steuerprüfung direkt gesagt, der diese zehn Kisten Bier hast du verkauft, für die hast du Einkünfte, ja? Das heißt, du brauchst kein, du sagst, okay, ich habe jetzt zweihundert Euro für zehn Kisten Bier ausgegeben und dann wird gesagt, ah, alles klar, du hast aber ähm
zweihundert äh sechshundert, siebenhundert Euro eingenommen damit. Weil ähm,
Du verkaufst die Flasche fit für drei Euro und hast es ja nicht weggegossen.
Und das führt dann dazu, dass die, dass die Kneipen so hingehen müssen und Getränke außerhalb der,
Rechnungsstellung kaufen, ne, also versuchen, Getränke schwarz zu kaufen, schwarz zu verkaufen und so weiter. Und was da getan wird, was man diesen Gewerben jetzt äh,
auferlegt legen möchte in Zukunft sind sogenannte Registerkassen, also Kassen, die im Prinzip den Umsatz in dem Moment, wo der gebucht wird schon dem Finanzamt sagen
und dann hast du in in anderen Ländern Europas ähm eine Belegpflicht,
Ja, das heißt du musst über noch so egal wie groß oder wie klein die Transaktion ist, du musst sie quittieren.
Ja und da ist natürlich die Hoffnung, dass wenn die Taranta Transaktion eben quittiert ist, dann heißt das du,
So funktioniert ja dieses Quittungswesen. Du hast diese Zahlung quittiert, also schwebt über dir das da Moklesschwert, wenn du diese diese Einkunft nicht in deine in deine Steuererklärung mit übernimmst.
Nachweisen kann, dass es aber stattgefunden.
Dass man dir das nachweisen kann, weil der die Person, der du den Beleg gegeben hast, diesen Beleg eben unter Umständen in ihre Steuererklärung holt, ja? Er ist so relativ ähm relativ krasse Gesetze in Italien und natürlich auch nochmal ein ganz anderes äh Problem mit
äh Schwarzgeld und so haben,
Ich finde das ähm ganz spannend, weil natürlich Steuerhinterziehung ähm schon ein relativ asozialer Akt ist.
Ähm,
Gleichzeitig eine Vollüberwachung der Finanzströme äh in dieser Form eben auch ein eine sehr sehr starke ist in in das die Freiheit ähm,
der Bürger und Bürgerinnen, ja, Frankreich hat es schon ähm, hat übrigens das das Cap bei tausend Euro Griechenland bei fünfhundert,
Fünfhundert Euro gibt in Griechenland kaum noch jemand aus, weil die äh Wirtschaft bei denen völlig am Boden liegt. Ähm.
Aber besonders gut ist das natürlich nicht, eine äh eine Gesellschaft in Richtung volldigitalisierter Währung zu schieben.
Ich meine der Trend ist auch ohnehin ja auch schon voll am Laufen. Da ist Deutschland schon fast eine Ausnahme, wenn da irgendwie äh durch Amsterdam läuft, dann wirst du schon viele Läden antreffen, die überhaupt gar kein Bargeld mehr nehmen.
Anderen Erwägungen vielleicht, indem sie einfach das generell,
sich sagen wir mal auch das Missbrauchspotential durch ihre Mitarbeiter äh reduzieren wollen oder überhaupt einfach auch so eine voll automatisierte Abrechnung setzen und da gar keine Häufchen mehr bilden wollen äh beziehungsweise natürlich auch Kosten
entstehen durch die Bereitstellung von Kleingeld, durch Banken, die ja dann auch dem äh Unternehmen unter Umständen Rechnung gestellt werden für den Aufwand, dass da irgendwie riesige Rollen mit Cent und so weiter hast, also
es geht sozusagen von beiden Enden, ne? Es gibt jetzt sozusagen sowohl um wie jetzt in dieser Debatte um große Summen,
Darum geht's ja hier zunächst einmal in diesem Popo, ne, dass man sozusagen sagt, Bargeld nur in einem Minimalbereich, aber auf der anderen Seite kommt auch so der Druck von unten
ein und zwei Cent ist eh nichts mehr wert, das ist den Aufwand uns sozusagen nicht wert,
eben das Bargeld eben von beiden Seiten angegangen wird, bis es dann eben potentiell irgendwann überhaupt gar keine Rolle mehr spielt, beziehungsweise wie so ein erreichen, indem man damit so wenig mehr anfangen kann,
Das ist fast unmöglich ist, nicht digital zu bezahlen.
Du kannst noch andere mit diesen mit diesen Münzen fällt mir gerade ein. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, weil ich habe eine Vermutung, von welchem Land das war, weil mir die Anekdote ist ungeprüft, aber die hatten das Problem, dass sie durch ähm fortschreitende,
Inflation irgendwann ihre Münzen. Der Nennwert der Münzen unter dem Materialwert war,
und dass die Leute halt dann massenhaft die eine zwei Centmünzen genommen und eingeschmolzen haben, weil weil.
Also er war mit dem Rohstoff dann wiederum mehr verdient.
Weil der Rohstoff mehr wert war als als das, was auf der Mütze draufsteht.
Naja, kann auch passieren.
Ist er, gibt's auch und glaube ich diese diese zehn D Mark-Münzen aus Silber, die unterliegen auch teilweise solchen äh solchen Schwankungen, wenn ich das, wenn ich das nicht äh falsch erinnere. Ähm.
Kann gut sein. Ich meine, machen wir uns nix vor. Der, der, der Trend zum digitalen Bezahlen wird sich äh kaum aufhalten lassen,
Das ist äh etwas, das kommt, allein aus Sicherheits- und Conventionsgründen, ne, teilweise ist halt einfach auch die digitale äh das digitale Bezahlwesen, einfach inneren, sicherer als äh
als es mit den derzeitigen Methoden
Also auch mit den derzeitigen digitalen Methoden ist, also es wird sozusagen sich da noch äh weiter verschärfen und es wird noch mehr im Bereich Convenience gehen, sprich also kontaktloses Bezahlen.
Also ich würde da jetzt vehement widersprechen, dass digitales Bezahlen momentan sicherer ist als äh Bargeldzahlung, aber im äh im im im Großen und Ganzen stimmt das natürlich.
Lässt sich nicht so leicht klauen. Also Sicherheit jetzt auf verschiedenen.
Ist da der entsprechende Vortrag.
Ja
Beim Congress insofern wäre ich da äh wäre ich da jetzt vorsichtig jetzt über die Sicherheit äh solcher Systeme ein abschließendes Urteil äh zu bilden, aber
Wie gesagt, selbst wenn sich da Sicherheitslücken finden, hast du eben durch diese
Dokumentation der Transaktion, da daraus ergibt sich ja die Sicherheit. Und das ist ja interessanterweise auch bei der bei dieser ganzen Bitcoin-Geschichte am Ende der äh der der Trust Anker, ja, also Bitcoin
viel gefeiert, als dieses anonym anonyme Mittel, was ja,
letztendlich das genaue Gegenteil davon ist, nämlich der Bitcoin ist eigentlich die Idee, dass die gesamt Anzahl aller Transaktionen,
und der und damit der Kontostand eines jeden Einzelnen.
Komplett nachvollziehbar ist.
Vollständig nachvollziehbar ist.
Na ja, das ist ein pseudonym ist System.
Ein, ja, ein pseudonymes, volldokumentiertes System. Das nur das nur am Rande.
Das heißt, da gehört es auch so, könntest du tatsächlich äh ähm,
Quasi sehen, wenn wenn man jetzt diese Grenze weltumspannend hätte, darf man man darf nicht mehr als so und so viel transferieren. Könntest du quasi in der Blockchain gucken, wer das gemacht hat.
Ja gut, was halten wir denn jetzt von dieser äh Initiative mit dem Bargeld? Also die Datenschützer äh schreien auf jeden Fall auf und äh sind erstmal so ein bisschen dagegen,
So liest man das zumindest hier aus allen äh Liegenartikeln heraus
Es ist aber schon auch eben wirklich so ein Ding, wo äh eine Abwägung wahrscheinlich einfach stattfinden wird. Aus all diesen genannten Gründen und wo eben man jetzt nicht so eine klare Antwort geben kann. Ich finde die die Abschaffung von Bargeld an sich,
die ja so in der Form noch nicht diskutiert wird oder zumindest auch überhaupt nicht auch nur im Ansatz.
Riesenproblem.
Äh mehrheitsfähig wäre, das wäre auf jeden Fall ein ein Problem. Frage ist, wenn man jetzt mal von diesem Popo ausgeht, von fünftausend Euro,
Wäre das bereits ein Problem. Also ist sozusagen auch eine, sind auch Zahlungen äh über fünftausend Euro ein Problem. Ich finde die Grenze schon.
Gefühlt etwas niedrig.
Weil man für fünftausend Euro eigentlich auch immer weniger bekommt. Also, was weiß ich, kann ich dann keinen Gebrauchtwagen mehr bar bezahlen, so und ist das sozusagen schon ein Problem? Ja, vielleicht, weil,
kritisch finde ich's ab dem Moment, wo man sagen kann, hier,
geht es sozusagen in so eine private Finanztransaktionswelt rein, die auch von.
Und tauschen und passt schon äh Schenkung und so weiter geprägt sind, die eben wirklich,
nicht unbedingt auch so unter wirtschaftlichen Aspekten abgehört werden muss. Das könntest du natürlich dann immer noch tun, könntest immer noch jemanden
Sechstausend Euro geben, weil das ja in dem Sinne keine äh ist die Frage, denn hier geht's ja um Rechnungen oder? Hier geht's sozusagen um Bezahlung für äh wirtschaftliche Transaktion. Das heißt ja nicht, du darfst niemand sechstausend Euro geben.
Was du machst ist, du kaufst halt erst die erste Hälfte von dem Auto für drei und dann verkauft er dir die andere Hälfte von dem Auto auch noch für nochmal drei.
Auto und dann noch das Ersatzradnummer.
Genau solche. Also das wären wirst du halt am Ende dann machen, ne. Ähm.
Ich habe da tatsächlich keine keine abschließende Meinung zu. Ich ähm kenne weniger Anwendungsfälle für Transaktionen ähm,
Über fünftausend Euro, die,
Jetzt unmöglich machen würden, da eine oder dies zu einer, sagen wir mal, nicht vertretbaren Würde machen würden, dass man diese Transaktion digital regelt,
Ja? Also ich würde jetzt in meinem Leben wäre ich glaube ich ein einziges Mal an an diese Grenze gekommen, also es gäbe eine einzige Transaktion in meinem Leben, die ähm dieser Pflicht unterfallen würde.
Insofern wäre ich da selten von betroffen. Und es ist gleichzeitig, gibt es äh natürlich sehr viele ähm.
Wirtschaftszweige, die da sehr gegen sein werden, weil sie davon profitieren, dass äh hohe Beträge in bar gezahlt werden und sie keine Fragen stellen, wo dieses Geld herkommt. Ähm,
Beispielsweise,
Ähm diese gesamte Luxusgüterindustrie, ja. Ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass so Juweliere ein völlig utopischen äh hohen Anteil an Bargeldzahlungen haben.
Ähm Luxusfahrzeughersteller ähm ne? Immer wieder beschrieben die Leute, die in Jogginghose mit einer Aldi-Tüte reinkommen und äh Porsche kaufen, ja? Das sind ähm
das sind Bereiche, die davon profitieren,
Gleichzeitig ähm gibt es unter Umständen Dinge, die man,
und dokumentiert kaufen möchte und wo man ein gutes Recht hat, diese Dinge äh und dokumentiert zu kaufen,
die über fünftausend Euro kosten können. Meint ein Auto ist jetzt so eine Sache, aber ähm was weiß ich? Ich glaube, du kannst zum Beispiel relativ schnell
für Hardware oder besonders geschützte Hardware oder besonders besondere Schutzmaßnahmen Geld ausgeben, dass über fünftausend Euro geht und möchtest nicht dokumentiert haben, dass du der Käufer eines besonderen Kryptogerätes oder sonst etwas bist.
Und da werden mit im Rahmen der Inflation natürlich die,
immer mehr Dinge drunter fallen in den nächsten Jahren. Also dieser Betrag fünftausend Euro wird immer weniger werden und immer mehr wird über fünftausend Euro kosten.
Was ich äh überlesen hatte in dem Artikel, wird übrigens auch äh gesagt, dass es ein solches Limit bereits unter anderem in Frankreich.
Ja ja genau, Frankreich, tausend Euro, Griechenland fünfhundert.
Genau. Ist schon relativ niedrig.
Das ist relativ niedrig.
Tausend Euro, also da kann man sich ja jetzt noch nicht mal äh eben eine Bahnkarte mit kaufen.
Zum Beispiel mit fünftausend auch nicht, wenn der erste Klasse fährst.
Auch schon ein paar Mal äh bar gemacht und zwar weil halt die digitale Bezahlung, das ist dann übrigens auch nochmal ganz interessant, ja auch in zunehmenden Maße mit Transaktions äh
daher kommt, also gerade bei äh meinem einen Bank äh Konto wurde das sozusagen einseitig jetzt von der äh Bank einfach mal so ausgerufen, dass da jetzt sozusagen ein, ein, ein Limit besteht in Höhe von dreitausend Euro war das, glaube ich
was ich mir dann sozusagen online ja, äh kurzfristig hochsetzen kann und so weiter, um an der Stelle äh vorzuverhindern, also,
Das ist äh.
Grundsätzlich
finde ich ganz gut, wenn der Kreditrahm nicht so hoch ist äh oder ist eine eine Begrenzung gibt für Transaktionen, ist natürlich eine völlig beknackte Sicherheitsmaßnahme, wenn alles, was du machen musst, nur einmal da anrufen ist, ja, aber zum Beispiel irgendwie bestimmte.
Muss mich da online einloggen, das ist total sicher, weil da muss ich ja mein Passwort.
Das würde der Angreifer ja nie hinkriegen. Ähm.
Die Sorge, meine Sorge, also genau, das ist etwas, was nicht was was am Ende ein ein unschön Kollateralschaden hat, ähm.
Dass man eben nicht mehr in der Lage sein wird
Produkte über einen gewissen Preis ähm und dokumentiert und ohne Nachweis zu kaufen. Und das wird wiederum natürlich eine ähm eine Linie aufmachen an,
illegal im Geschäft, nämlich dass du sagst, ah wunderbar, ja, ich kaufe das für dich, klar. Also nur, weil das verboten wird, heißt es ja nicht, dass die Leute das nicht mehr machen. Letztendlich wirst du da also quasi so ein Geschäftsmodell,
Einem Geschäftsmodell Tür und Tor öffnen, äh was darin besteht,
Ähm ja, Geld zu waschen in dieser Form, ja? Und zu sagen, okay, du möchtest diesen Ferrari kaufen, kein Problem, geht, so, ne?
Kostet dich halt zehn Prozent mehr, den in bar zu bezahlen, dann kauf ich den und setzt den ab als Firmenwagen, also da werden halt die Geflechte,
In der Steuerhinterziehung eben,
ja, komplexer werden. Was aber gut ist für die Steuerfahnder, weil je komplexer die sind, desto leichter, desto einfacher sind sie dann auch am Ende wieder auseinanderzunehmen.
Ja, keine Ahnung, kann ich, wie gesagt, habe ich, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, ob ich da dafür oder dagegen bin,
da wäre dann auch nochmal irgendwie so ein bisschen Evidenzbasiertes Herangehen spannend zu sehen, na ja wie viel äh.
Wie viel der Transaktion über diesen Wert sind denn tatsächlich,
sagen wir mal, offene Weise schützenswert, wie viele Transaktionen sind äh stehen im Verdacht? Ähm,
Schwarzgeld zu sein oder Geldwäsche zu sein, weil wie gesagt, Geldwäsche halte ich hier ein bisschen für was anderes, weil Geldwäsche,
machst du in Kleinbeträgen, die du irgendwo wieder einem Steuersystem zuführst, insofern ist der Geldwäsche hier nicht der richtige Begriff,
Wenn du also Geld wäschst du, wie gesagt, indem du eine, indem du ein Restaurant hast, in dem keiner essen geht und diese diese Beträge halt äh dann wieder versteuerst und quasi deine deinen Kokainhandel äh,
so wieder irgendwo das Geld, was du als Kokainehandel hast im Restaurant halt einzuführen, um es dann am Ende wieder auch auf wirklich auf deinem Konto haben zu
können, damit nicht die Leute eine die ganze Zeit Kokain verkaufst, die irgendwann die Tür eintreten und die Berge Bargeld suchen, die du zu Hause hortest. Das ist Geldwäsche,
ja? Ähm hier geht's eher darum, das Geld nicht zu waschen und in Luxusgüter umzusetzen.
Sagen, dein Fachwissen beeindruckt mich.
Ich setze mich mit äh mit äh solchen Systemen äh auseinander, natürlich. Also ich habe da äh.
Mhm. Keine Frage, euer Herr.
Nein, aber also das also ich setze mich mit Zahlungssystem auseinander, unter anderem beruflich und äh.
Ja nee, ist ist schon klar. Es ist rübergekommen.
Und ich bin ja auch äh so na ja.
Die Begriffe müssen da scharf getrennt sein.
So, damit sind wir mit dem harten politischen Brot eigentlich äh eigentlich weitgehend durch.
Jetzt sind wir noch auf was auf eine Story hingewiesen, von der ich mir gar nicht so sicher bin, ob die hier eigentlich wirklich so reinpasst. Ähm.
Aber vielleicht kann man das einfach mal aufgreifen und da auch mal so ein ja einen kulturellen äh wirtschaftskulturellen Blick aufs Netz äh,
aufmachen. Worum geht's? Also es gibt da.
Landschaft seit langer langer Zeit zwei äh Herren Brüder
Benni und Raffi Fein, die unter dem Namen Fine Brothers. Äh vor allem durch äh ihre Serie an,
sogenannten Videos bekannt geworden ist.
Was ist das? Das ist so einfach die Idee, es gibt irgendwie Erzeugnis X und dann nimmst du dir äh eine beliebige Zahl, irgendwelcher äh Personen und setzt sie diesem Erzeugnis X aus und filmst sie dabei wie sie darauf reagieren, während sie das dann,
oft zum ersten Mal oder vielleicht auch zum wiederholten Mal sehen und das ist dann irgendwie interessant. Und die haben da so einen gewissen,
Modus gefunden, ein gewisses Format entwickelt. Ähm ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel Bandbreite das hat, aber üblicherweise sieht das so aus, man sieht halt dann so, keine Ahnung, Kinder reagieren auf,
alte Technik, dann steht,
Wählscheibentelefon und dann sollen die Kinder irgendwie rausbekommen, was äh denn damit ist. Und die Reaktionen sind dann in der Regel ganz äh aufschlussreich oder lustig oder im besten Fall beides.
Und dann gibt's vielleicht noch eine kleine Fragerunde dazu, wo dann äh die Kinder sozusagen nochmal explizit befragt werden, was sie denn aus weiß ich aus irgendeinem Video heraus gelernt haben.
So und das sind sozusagen diese Formate, die sie machen. Diese Foundbrothers sind auch ansonsten ziemlich umtriebig und haben auch so allerlei äh andere Dinge,
produziert, ich kann das jetzt nur so ein bisschen wiedergeben, ich kenn zwar diese Projektvideos, hab da auch schon einige von gesehen, ist halt ab und zu mal ganz lustig so,
mir jetzt in der Regel nicht so viel, aber findet durchaus Freunde und sie haben da, was weiß ich, schon dreizehn Millionen,
Abonnenten soweit so gut. Das Ganze tritt halt auf äh unter dem Namen Fine Brothers. Entertainment und die haben dann auch schon in andere Bereiche,
hinein Myandad äh wohl ganz erfolgreich war, so eine,
Sitcom äh unter dem Namen My Music, die so ein bisschen aufgefallen ist, weil sie halt auf der einen Seite so ein war, also so so tut, als wäre es so die Dokumentation eines Unternehmens,
irgendwie lustig rüberkommt,
weil sie das eben auch äh transmedial angehen, also sozusagen auch ausbrechen aus dem Video und äh YouTube-Format und das mit anderen Medienwegen kombinieren,
Egal, da kann ich jetzt auch gar nicht so viel zu erzählen. Soweit, so gut, äh nichts wäre weiter passiert, nur haben sie jetzt äh.
Eine Ankündigung gemacht, dass sie ihr Business äh erweitern, um eine Welt, nämlich die,
in der sie ganz uneigennützig ähm,
ihre Formate öffnen für andere und ihr Angebot war im Wesentlichen dieses, so ihr wollt auch React Videos machen,
dann äh wollen wir euch dabei helfen,
indem wir euch bei der Produktion helfen und vor allem erlauben wir euch, dass ihr unser Format, unsere Format Idee, unsere unser Konzept von Reaktvideos,
kopiert oder zur Anwendung bringt in dem Moment und vergleichen das eben auch mit sowas wie äh was weiß ich hier so diese Talentshows äh Deutschland sucht den Superstar et cetera
diese ganzen äh Formate, der ganze TV ja schon seit längerer Zeit gibt,
Und man könnte dann denn eben in diesen Genuss äh kommen von ja, das funktioniert ja eh schon und,
die Leute, worauf sich äh einstellen und sie würden ja auch dafür Werbung machen. Und natürlich aber auch zwanzig Prozent der daraus gewonnenen Werbeeinnahmen für sich behalten.
Gut, kann man sagen, klare Dienstleistungen, alles äh super, aber irgendwie sind den äh Weberfahrenen Feinbrothers äh wohl ein bisschen die Golde durchgegangen und sie haben so in ihrer Ankündigung äh so ein paar,
Töne angestimmt, die zu Verstimmung und komischen Resonanzen geführt haben. Auf jeden Fall gab's auf einmal eine riesige Aufregung,
weil sie halt auch so ein bisschen äh drauf eingetrommelt haben, dass man ja dann auch irgendwie dazu beitragen sollte, wenn jetzt irgendjemand das kopier, das Format, sollte man das auch melden, weil das geht ja nicht und das wäre ja dann sozusagen ihr,
weiß nicht genau, welche Formulierungen sie da jetzt gewählt haben. Also quasi,
haben sie so ein wenig den den Teufel auch mit an die Wand gemalt in ihren Ausführungen, äh dass es ja nicht ginge, wenn sozusagen die Zinsformate jetzt ohne ihre Beteiligung von zwanzig Prozent da äh ablaufen würden.
Dann damit haben sie sich dann ein,
Shitstorm eingetreten, weil auf einmal so eine YouTube-Gemeinschaft dann aufgestanden ist und gesagt hat, hm, jetzt haben wir aber so ein bisschen Angst vor euch, weil was soll denn diese Andeutung? Äh habt ihr jetzt sozusagen vor, alles abzumahnen, was,
bei drei nicht auf den Bäumen ist und das Wort verwendet. Tatsächlich haben sie sich ihre ganzen Showtitel als Trademark eingetragen, das wohl schon vor,
äh drei, vier Jahren, also so was auch immer äh,
Hitlers, Hitler-Reacts war wohl nicht dabei.
Also es gibt natürlich relativ viele Hitler-Reacts to the fine Bros, React Trade Mark Videos, also ist klar.
Ja, die habe ich noch nicht äh gesehen, aber ist klar, dass äh auch Hitler sich dazu natürlich äußern muss, ne. Nein, wirklich.
Ist nein.
Aber in also die sind jetzt auch hier meine Primärquelle, weil da wird jetzt in, also in diesem Hitlervideo wird Hitler eröffnet, sie wollen die wollten sich wirklich quasi react,
aber das ist ja ein zu generischer Begriff oder kann man sich den Trade-Marken?
Also, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist wohl auch,
Davon die Rede in dieser Tretmarkanmeldung, dass das Wort in diesem Zusammenhang eine Rolle spielen kann, aber es ist nicht so, dass jetzt
das Wort Reakt selber ein Tretmark wäre und ich glaube, das würden auch so die Regeln so nicht ohne Weiteres zulassen. Aber es mag so Formulierungen geben, da schwimme ich jetzt ein wenig, aber so habe ich das rausgehört aus den Reaktionen, dass äh
sagen wir mal berücksichtigt werden kann bei der Bewertung, ob etwas äh gegen diese Trademark verstößt oder nicht.
Bist du komplett auf Hitler wieder.
Also lass gegen Argumente sind doch relativ überzeugend. Na ja also,
Das worauf halt hingewiesen wird, ist, dass jetzt so äh Reaction Videos jetzt nicht das ähm nicht unbedingt das Neuste sind, ne, dass es die halt gibt äh seit ähm.
Seit der Machtergreifung.
Seit äh seit es irgendwelche Videos mit mit Bechern gab und so weiter und äh sage ich jetzt nicht, das werde ich jetzt hier nicht ansprechen, worauf er da Bezug nimmt, aber es geht also schon relativ lange Reaction-Videos,
es möchte, glaube ich, auch niemand behaupten, das erfunden zu haben. Ähm.
Und das, das, das tun sie in dem Sinne auch gar nicht und das ist halt aber trotzdem ganz interessant, dass das jetzt auch im Mittelpunkt äh der ganzen Geschichte zu stehen scheint. Ähm was wir vielleicht gar nicht so wussten, was ich bis vor Kurzem auch noch nicht wusste, ist, diese ganze,
Tourgeschichte ist,
auch etwas, was es schon im amerikanischen Fernsehen wohl zuhauf gegeben hat und das auch schon seit langer, langer Zeit. Also das ist auch jetzt nichts, was jetzt mit dem Internet geboren wurde. Die haben das sozusagen in diesen konkreten Formaten für YouTube urba gemacht und
Das ist jetzt wiederum auch interessant, weil sie ja meinen so, ja, hier kopiert uns nicht, offenbar tut das derzeit auch keiner
Also es gibt natürlich tausend Videos, wo irgendjemand zu irgendwas reagiert, aber es gibt jetzt niemanden, der jetzt wirklich konkret ihr Format genau in dieser Form, wie sie das machen, ja, so mit diesen Kids.
Tun lalala. Am Anfang und dann äh auch mal diese spezifische Kameras,
die sie eben so von vorne links äh schräg nehmen, Laptop davor, mit irgendwie Logo aufm Laptop draufgeklebt und Pipapo und halt diese Frage runter, einfach dieser spezifische Stil
der ist sogar eigentlich gar nicht unter Feuer. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen den Eindruck, sie wollen eben mit ihrer Red World äh quasi auch die Bereiche, die sie es aus ihrem eigenen.
Vermögen heraus gar nicht so ohne weiteres adressieren können, sagen wir mal, China, Asien überhaupt sozusagen, diese wachsende äh Internetwelt, wo sich das eben jetzt ausbreitet, äh wollen sie
quasi Leute einladen, dasselbe Format in anderen Sprachen äh zu machen, was sie so gar nicht abdecken können, aber trotzdem damit mitzuverdienen, indem sie einfach da ihren
Brand quasi reinschaufeln und äh das eben mit vertreiben, mit bewerben, et cetera
Was ja jetzt, sagen wir mal auch erstmal so äh vollkommen in Ordnung ist, das können sie ja gerne machen, nur dass eben sozusagen YouTube jetzt als
Community und sie reden auch die ganze Zeit von einer Community, die sie aufbauen wollen, aber diese Community will sich an der Stelle nicht vereinnahmen lassen und äh hat sozusagen Angst vor
äh
Wandel. Das habe ich so aus einem anderen Reaction-Video auf diese ganze Geschichte so herausgelesen. Ja, wir wollen ja gar nicht, dass ich den, ihr wollt jetzt die Welt ändern, aber wir wollen ja gar nicht, dass die Welt sich ändern. Wir wollen ja so äh wir wollen es ja so, wie es schon immer war.
Es in YouTube gibt es jetzt seit zehn Jahren und diese ganze Showkultur vielleicht seit
sechs oder so, keine Ahnung, sieben vielleicht. Äh ja, aber jetzt darf sich da sozusagen auf einmal schon mal gar nichts äh dran ändern und deswegen geht es halt jetzt irgendwie hin und her. Also das ist äh schwierig, ne? Ich meine YouTuber haben dann an der Stelle ähm,
Ist ganz interessant, ne? Also wir würden gerne mit euch arbeiten, aber nicht für euch oder äh äh das ist jetzt sozusagen das Eindringen von Corporate America und wir haben's jetzt auch schon
quasi die Konkurrenz durch das amerikanische Fernsehen, die ja auch im zunehmenden Maße in YouTube präsent wird, ne, so John Oliver, solche Shows, also populäre Talkshows, vor allem aus dem US-Fernsehen, die ja extrem
ähm populär sind, im äh natürlich auch im Netz, also die an sich populär sind, aber die natürlich dann auch im Netz besonders,
populär werden und die auch teilweise ja auch schon exklusiv für das Web auch mitproduzieren. Ne, also ich habe jetzt gerade gesehen hier John Oliver,
hat nicht nur seine Shows im Netz, sondern jetzt wo er gerade nicht im Fernsehen ist,
Januar so eine Winterpause einlegt, hauen sie dann immer mal wieder so fünf Minuten Clips nur fürs Web raus. Einfach um da die Spannung aufrechtzuerhalten und Leute da nichts zu verlieren.
Ja, was spielt da jetzt mit rein? Mit Copyreiter hat das nicht so viel zu tun. Ein paar Sachen fand ich ganz interessant. Äh das halt hier,
ähm natürlich in dem Moment, wo man auch,
Reactvideos macht ja unter Umständen auch diesen Content auf den reagiert wird gegebenenfalls auch mit zeigen muss, um überhaupt auch mal zu erklären, worum's eigentlich geht, auch wenn es bei diesen,
Reactvideos von den in der Regel gar nicht so ohne weiteres zu sehen ist, manchmal schon, manchmal nicht,
das mit den Bechern, glaube ich, nicht, aber andere Sachen schon, so Justin Bieber oder so, damit man das irgendwie so ein bisschen beurteilen kann, worauf jetzt auch gerade reagiert wird. Und dann hast du natürlich wieder dieses Copyright-Problem,
was ist, wenn ich diesen Content nehme? Und in USA ist aber da eben an der Stelle eine ganze Menge möglich, eben durch FairUse, ne, wobei man sich auch fragen muss, okay, was ist faire? Ist jetzt react, ist das eine journalistische Betrachtung?
Ja, weil so richtig
Inhaltlich ist das ja jetzt nicht. Das sind irgendwie ganz putzige Videos. Okay, ha ha, ist lustig. Es ist im Wesentlichen Unterhaltung und keine gesellschaftliche Debatte, ne. Äh das ist jetzt sozusagen nicht so wichtig. Stellen sie zwar in ihrem eigenen Video da, dass das ja eine unglaubliche Bedeutung für die
die Geschichte und was weiß ich, die Zukunft natürlich auch der Welt hat. Dass äh manche nachschlagen kann, wie Leute vor dreißig Jahren auf Justin Biber Videos reagiert haben.
Sagen die ernsthaft?
Du kennst auch diese hyperbolischen äh Übertreibungen, das ist ja da irgendwie auch ganz normal, ne. Ja, also äh.
Also die scheinen doch ehrlich, also ich die Frage ist eigentlich, warum machen die das? Ja, wenn sie kein ähm wenn's jetzt keinen Übermaß an dokumentierten äh Imitationsfällen gibt,
gegen die sie sich schützen wollten, fällt das ja wohl irgendwie raus, das heißt
Vermutlich scheint das die Bar, also scheinen scheinen sie den Grundstein für eine Form von ähm Expansionsstrategie legen zu wollen. Ja, also irgendwie in Sprachen und Länder, die sie sich selber nicht erschließen können. Äh zu gehen.
Genau oder auch eine Handhabe zu haben für so für, ich meine.
Zu machen. Und dann natürlich äh entsprechend.
In Zukunft wird es halt solche dann Formatkopie natürlich auch geben, dem wollen sie vielleicht präventiv da.
Haben Sie jetzt mit dem mit dem Stunt auf jeden Fall schon mal nicht hingekriegt, weil jetzt machen das allein zwanzig Leute nur, um die zu ärgern. Ähm.
Ich die das Problem, es scheint ja so ein bisschen zu sein ähm was,
dass diese YouTube-Stars eben alle irgendwie mal so ein bisschen so independent Underdog, selfmade Sachen. Leute waren,
und sich da jetzt inzwischen eben ein Markt entwickelt hat, wo sich klassische,
Marktaufteilungsstrukturen auch irgendwie ergeben wollen, ja? Dass Leute irgendwie
was weiß ich, vielleicht sagen, okay, jetzt habe ich mir hier alles erschlossen, jetzt äh möchte ich, mache ich ein Franchise draus und lasse das noch weiterwachsen, weil man selber ja auch nicht die Diversität
äh bieten kann, um sich so ein um sich noch größere Marktanteile zu holen im Angebot, ja. Ähm.
Und darauf reagieren so Communitys eben nicht besonders äh wohlgesonnen,
Ja, vor allem, wenn du so doof bist wie die, und quasi deine Marktstrategie ankündigst, bevor du sie irgendwie mit Leben füllst, ja? Wenn die jetzt andersrum hingegangen wären und sich, sage ich mal, ein paar ähm.
Paar äh Alternativshows äh aus dem Boden gestampft hätten, ja? Und zum Beispiel gesagt hätten, okay, wir wollen irgendwie Projektkram
in Japan anbieten, schnappen uns ein Japan, japanisches Team, was so etwas macht, ähm geben den Anschubfinanzierung
und gehen dann irgendwann hin und sagen, ey schaut mal hier, da haben wir noch einen YouTube-Star geschaffen mit unserer Hilfe und der macht auch coole Videos und wenn ihr auch so cool sein wollt und in,
Was weiß ich, da und da wohnt, dann helfen wir euch auch oder so, ja?
Dann wäre da deren diese dieses Geschäftsmodell, was sie da entwickelt haben, vielleicht auch positiver ähm von der Community ähm aufgenommen worden.
Ist die Frage, welcher Community, weil äh dieses Modell, was ich ja jetzt in der YouTube-Landschaft herausgebildet habe
nennt man Multichannel Network, ne? Das hast du ja hier auch so mit Mediakraft
das heißt, es gibt so Vermarktergruppen, die nehmen quasi schon halbwegs etablierte YouTube-Formate auf, unter ihre Fittiche, vermarkten das, sind natürlich dann an den Einnahmen entsprechend
beteiligt, haben äh da Verträge, aber setzen eben quasi schon auf kleine Stars, die äh ihre eigenen Community bereits,
Erarbeitet haben. Das Modell jetzt ist ja ein ganz anderes. Hier kann ja im Prinzip jemand auch ohne,
dass schon irgendetwas erarbeitet worden ist, einfach mit etwas Unterstützung auch sehr einfaches Format in gewisser Hinsicht. Ähm hier mit dazustoßen, ohne sich das überhaupt schon erst noch erarbeitet haben zu müssen und damit.
War sie ja auch eine Chance bekommt, ähm die Vorarbeit anderer einfach für sich mitzunutzen,
das quasi so als als Kick-off äh Finanzierung oder zumindest Modell äh zu erhalten. Das ist natürlich eigentlich,
Auch ein interessantes Angebot an eine Community. Ja, wir helfen euch sogar hier, einen Einstieg äh zu schaffen, selbst wenn ihr noch nicht irgendwie euch selbst etabliert habt,
Natürlich auch sagen,
Ist ja eigentlich auch eine schöne Chance, die da äh geboten wird. Also auch hier fällt es mir schwer, da eine klare Position zu beziehen, finde es aber nur ganz interessant, dass wir offensichtlich in der YouTube-Welt, in dieser äh,
der den anderen Massenmedien ja am ähnlichsten, Netzkultur äh im Prinzip auch einen Generationswechsel,
sich ablesen lässt. Also wir haben jetzt quasi schon so ein erstes Katzenjahr durch, ne? Da sagt man Hunde ja.
Und her.
Hunde ja. Sieben Jahre, ja? Lebe das jetzt irgendwie,
und jetzt kommt so eine neue Generation nach oder die erste Generation, die da war, äh entwickelt sich quasi weiter,
spielt jetzt auf einem anderen Level mit, hat eine ganz eigene Kraft und versucht das mit äh eigenen Ideen jetzt in eine andere Richtung äh zu ähm schieben und dieser Wahrnehmung, dass so die Youtuber, so eine homogene Masse sind,
die äh schwindet, weil das das war sie wahrscheinlich nie, aber das das war ja schon so ein bisschen das Gespräch in den letzten Jahren.
Nahm.
Vergleiche das doch mal mit, also solche Bewegungen hast du doch an anderen Stellen auch. Ich meine, ich erinnere mich ähm vage als irgendwie Edical oder das ist dann nachher Ethnation, dieses Blogger Vermarktungsnetz von Spreeblick,
Da sind ja auch wenn ich das recht erinnere irgendwie böse Stimmen laut geworden, die das irgendwie nicht in Ordnung fanden und haste nicht gesehen,
verkauft ihr hier die Szene aus und ähm.
Geht das auch selber natürlich ganz anders an.
Selbstverständlich seien die das anders, ja. Ähm würde man vielleicht jetzt auch im Nachhinein könnte man das mal in Frage stellen. Also ich meine, ich habe äh,
ich kenne die Zeiten, die es noch sehr gut und die werden auch,
irgendwann vermutlich nochmal kommen, ähm wo Netzpolitik org ähm Schwierigkeiten hatte, das irgendwie zu bezahlen ist, dieses Theater, ja. Und ähm.
Dann gibt's aber da irgendwie diese Leute, die sagen, das muss jetzt alles aus Idealismus sein. Da gibt's auch gute Gründe für.
Dass das irgendwie alles aus Idealismus sein muss, aber irgendwann stößt du ihm mit so einem Projekt an, Grenzen. Und wir sind, ähm kann man ja vielleicht auch einfach mal oder zumindest meine Rolle hier in diesem Podcast
mal so beleuchten, ich finanziere mich halt auf anderem Wege,
So und dieses dieses Logbuch mache ich irgendwie seit vier Jahren als Hobby und mehr als irgendwie eine Hobby ähm.
Ein Hobby Dank über ein paar Flattern, paar PayPals und ein paar äh Daueraufträge auf mein Konto äh in in sehr geringen Beträgen kommt da eben auch nicht bei rum.
Wenn ich jetzt irgendwann wenn ich jetzt sage ich mal, wenn wir mit diesem Podcast einer größeren Professionalität zugeführt werden,
uns einer größeren Professionalität zuführen wollten, müssten wir uns auch irgendwie über diese Finanzierung des ganzen Dinges äh Gedanken machen. Ist aber irgendwie nix, was wir anstreben und deswegen ist das auch irgendwie halbwegs
läuft es halt so, wie es ist und ist cool
aber ähm größeres wie jetzt irgendwie eine Redaktion aufbauen, die Netzpolitik ORG bedeutet eben auch, dass du da mit den Leuten
dass du dir den an, dass du Leute anstellst und denen eine finanzielle Sicherheit gibst, so. Und dass die, dass du von diesen Leuten verlangst,
sich in eine vollständige Abhängigkeit von diesem Projekt zu begeben als ab als äh ne ähm Angestellte, als abhängig Beschäftigte und dass du gleichzeitig die die,
Das Problem hast, dass du dieses Geld dann eben auch ran schaffen musst. Und dann musst du dir irgendwie über belastbare Finanzierungsmodelle Gedanken machen. Und in dem Moment, wo du das machst, kriegst du öffentlich äh radikal äh auf auf die Nase. Ja?
Oder wir sagen einfach, ihr macht jetzt einfach auch einen Podcast, der heißt Logbuch irgendwas, ja?
Logbuch World.
Und dann nehmen wir da einfach zwanzig Prozent. Ja, Logbuch World und ähm.
So, ne.
War's. Ihr habt ja Witze gemacht, ja? Also.
Problem ist, das Problem ist, dass diese,
diese Leute oder die die Menschen, die eben aus solchen Communityprojekten, Community, Geliebten natürlich gewachsenen Dingen kommen, äh naturgemäß relativ schlechtes Häppchen dafür haben, äh Dinge zu vermarkten. Und ich glaube, das sieht man jetzt bei diesen,
Als nix anderes würde ich diese Jungs da sehen. Ja, wobei, das ist irgendwie ein USA-Ding, die werden schon äh ganz gut Geld verdienen damit. Also ich glaube nicht, dass die jetzt irgendwie äh dahingeht, in diese Sache getrieben wurden, weil sie irgendwie ihre Miete nicht mehr bezahlen.
Nö, das ist Expansion, ganz klar.
Ne? Und das ist halt Expansion,
Und äh Expansionen von Community Sachen wird kritisch gesehen und da gehöre ich auch zu denjenigen, die das äh kritisch beäugen.
Ja? Ähm gleichzeitig muss man aber, ne, also ich meine
irgendwie Engagement im Rahmen des CCC ist äh unter dem Strenge, unter der strengen Maßgabe, dass es eben, dass dann niemand Geld verdienen darf, auch keine geringsten Beträge,
Und ähm das hat den Flair dieser Veranstaltung aus und wenn der CCC sich jetzt hinstellen würde und sagt, wir äh was weiß ich, äh der CC ist Nowhiring,
ja? Wir brauchen zehn äh Praktikanten oder Praktikantin in der Veranstaltungsorgar, ja, dann würde das natürlich zu Recht einen auf die Nase geben.
Und gleichzeitig sieht man aber an einem Event, wie der Republika, dass es eben auch,
Anders geht, einen Community-Event zu veranstalten,
mit einer anderen Aufhängung, mit Sponsoren, mit äh ja dann doch auch irgendwie höheren Eintrittsgeldern und so weiter.
Kann man auch machen. Ja, geht auch und da kriegt man auch,
weiß ich nicht. Kein besonders nennenswerten Shitstorm oder muss das Projekt beerdigen, wenn man's so macht? Die Frage ist, wie man's halt angeht.
Das kann man eben geschickt machen und so, dass es die Leute verstehen oder eben nicht. Und vor allem muss man ja, sich in irgendeiner Form dann eben auch, ja.
Treu bleiben. Ähm ich habe aber jetzt irgendwie, ich sehe so wenig Veranlassung jetzt irgendwie ein Geschäftsmodell, was Menschen haben, ähm.
Als ein Angriff zu sehen,
auf mich als Nutzer oder Nichtnutzer. Ja, das die können sich halt entscheiden, dazu machen und dann ist es halt Kacke,
Und dann sind's halt der Buhmann und dann können sie sich halt überlegen, wie ähm,
wie das für sie läuft, ja? Ob sie da jetzt am Ende Gewinn machen und sagen dann, da müssen wir halt durch diesen Shitstorm durch. Gibt's genug Beispiele für. Ja, dass Projekte sagen, okay.
Diesen Schritt gehen wir jetzt, da müssen wir jetzt mal die die müssen wir jetzt mal die äh die Zähne zusammenbeißen und durchmarschieren und danach haben wir, was weiß ich
zehnfachen Umsatz und auch zehnfache Reichweite und am Rand stehen paar Leute und haben haben sich beklagt. Gut,
Und dann gibt's aber auch genug Beispiele dafür, wo Leute ähm sich da vertun,
Und am Ende ihre ihren kompletten Rückhalt verlieren und ihre Marke am Ende äh verspielt haben. Beide Fälle sind ähm sind als Außenstehender äh Beobachter ähm interessant
zu begutachten, ja. Ähm ich persönlich habe halt den den die Haltung dazu, dass ich.
Dass ich das lieber sehe als als ehrenamtliches Engagement
von von Menschen und das auch lieber selber als ehrenamtliches Engagement betreibe, aber man darf nicht vergessen, dass dieses das unternehme ich den CCC-Kongress eben als Beispiel
was da äh gemacht wird, was da geleistet wird, ähm was sich in den niedrigen Ticketpreisen niederschlägt und in dem in dem,
In dem großen Erfolg dieser Veranstaltung ist eben eine eine massive Selbstausbeutung,
da viele Menschen ähm betreiben und eben signifikantem Ausmaß betreiben.
Und das so
das geht so weiter, das geht so gut und das ist der Idealismus und dem möchte ich auch äh bei dieser bei dieser Veranstaltung halt behalten. Aber es ist eine, ich denke, man sollte schon anderen Veranstaltungen, die dann eben sagen, okay, nee, wir wollen hier irgendwie auch mal versuchen, Geld zu verdienen,
das nicht äh grundsätzlich negativ auslegen. Der Witz ist halt, wie sie's machen
ja? Und was für Communitys, irgendwelche Leute verkaufen wollen. Natürlich ist auch irgendwie diese diese ganze CCC-Sache immer wieder irgendwelchen oder diese Hacker-Community immer wieder irgendwelchen
versuchen oder Organisationen oder Events ausgesetzt, die versuchen diese diese Community irgendwie auszuverkaufen und daran Geld zu verdienen.
Nicht jeder, nicht jeder dieser Vorstöße ist grundsätzlich zu verteufeln, aber die meisten sind halt so dermaßen plump und dämlich, dass sie einfach nur nur fällen können.
Finde jetzt den Sprung von äh YouTube-Formaten in USA zum CCC, das ist schon ist er, ist ein Grundsatz, den man.
Eine Grundsatzdebatte. Ich will. Der Vergleich hinkt an mehreren Ebenen und.
Unabhängig davon, ob er hinkt oder nicht, finde ich, dass er nur einfach ein sehr großer Teich äh auch mit äh überschritten wird. Und wenn man's vielleicht mal so ein bisschen mehr in die Medien äh Welt bringt und dieses,
dieses Problem oder dieses diese diese Idee des ähm
Entertainment oder mit äh Infotainment oder Info auch alleine äh äh journalistisch oder auch nur teil journalistisch irgendwie ein Überleben zu sichern, das das
Das ist ja eine Debatte, die findet auf allen Ebenen statt, ne? Und.
Die Debatte ist deshalb lächerlich, weil diese YouTube-Leute seit jeher, also die wenigen YouTube-Stars, ja? Ähm,
seid, seid sie große YouTube-Stars sind, sehr gutes Geld damit verdienen, ja? Und da braucht man
wenn die auf diesen Geschäftsmodellen fußen und wenn sie irgendwie, was weiß ich,
Werbung unterbringen und Schleichwerbung unterbringen und irgendwie diese YouTube-Werbung, die da vorgeschaltet wird und was die nicht alles für Wege zur Monetarisierung und Selbstvermarktung finden. Dann brauche ich mich doch als Zuschauer nicht am Ende noch irgendwo hinzustellen
um mich über einen der Zweige, den sie jetzt auch noch suchen, ähm um um irgendwie Geld zu verdienen, damit äh jetzt irgendwie empört zeigen.
Ja, was ich ganz interessant fand, war das nee, nee, nee, nee, es ist äh absolut berechtigt und ähm wie gesagt, ich will das auch nicht, nicht groß werden. Ich finde es nur ganz interessant, dass zum Beispiel auch zumindest diese eine Reaktion dann auch so äh das sozusagen auch als,
Ähm weiterer Vormarsch von Corporate America äh gesehen wurde, so als als ob es sozusagen als ob's.
Als ob ausgerechnet YouTube-Videos jetzt die letzte Portion des Bastion, des des Antikapitalismus waren. Ja.
Ja, genau.
Sorry, wenn ich das vorher, wenn das vorher,
wenn ich das vorher nicht nicht explizit genug gesagt habe so, äh ich meine, dass wie gesagt, das kann ich doch nur interessiert und zynisch betrachten, als die Businessentscheidungen von irgendwelchen Businessleuten.
Ja, ja.
Da finde ich's halt da, dann haben sie sich halt vertan, was was die Einschätzung ihrer Marke eingeht und dann lehne ich mich zurück und gucke mir das mit Popcorn an.
So und kann ich also kann ich äh wie gesagt so, ich meine Logbuch wurde, wartet mal ab, Freunde.
Na ja, ich kann euch auf jeden Fall beruhigen, äh die Mieterebene äh hat noch nicht vor, die äh Community ähm an irgendwelche.
Irgendwelche Organisationen weiterzuverkaufen, da seid ihr ja sozusagen noch äh im sicheren Bereich, im Safe habe.
Die Brücke geschlagen, wieder zum Anfang der Sendung.
Ja, ich meine, wir könnten uns ja schon irgendwie Gedanken machen.
Nee, wir finden jetzt keine Monetarisierungsdiskussion.
Der deutsche Qualitätspodcast muss doch irgendwie auch.
Sendung, der deutsche Qualitätspodcast ist äh schon wieder viel zu lang. Ja.
Ey.
Weil ist ja wichtig oder hatten wir noch irgendwas?
Äh nee, kurze Meldung. Ähm,
Ich weiche, ich weiß gar nicht genau, ob das jetzt, ich glaube, es ist jetzt offiziell, ja? Ähm bekannt war es vorher auch schon, dass die, dass die dass diese
dass die Zahl für das Referendum gegen das Nachrichtendienstgesetz erreicht ist.
Welches?
Das Referendum gegen das Nachrichtendienstgesetz in der Schweiz.
Ja? Äh dass da ist ja das Gemeinschaftsprojekt von Chaos Computer Club Schweiz, digitale Gesellschaft, Schweiz und Piratenpartei, Schweiz und Grundrechte Punkt CH
sich mit einem Referendum gegen das neue Nachrichtendienstgesetz ähm und der Schweiz zu wenden. Ähm.
Da gab haben wir mehrfach drüber berichtet, dass sie sich über die Unverhältnismäßigkeit, die Irreführung, die Gefahr, die Unvereinbarkeit dieses Gesetzes,
ähm,
und den nicht den nicht vorhandenen Notstand der der das irgendwie rechtfertigen würde ein solches Gesetz wenden. Und sie haben ja auch relativ schnell äh ihre Zahl an Unterschriften zusammen gehabt.
Aber jetzt haben sie es nee, die haben, glaube ich, noch viel mehr. Ähm.
Also elftausend waren erforderlich.
Waren erforderlich, aber ich glaube, die sind irgendwo bei fünfundfünfzigtausend oder so, die Seite ist relativ informationsarm. Ähm,
aber ich habe in einem Tweet gelesen, dass sie sagen, so jetzt haben sie also quasi auch offiziell oder sie haben offiziell dieses Referendum zusammen zustande bekommen,
und die Abstimmung wird voraussichtlich bereits am fünften Juni zweitausendsechzehn stattfinden,
Ja? Also Referendum funktioniert ja so, du sagst, du willst Referendum haben und dann musst du erstmal nennenswert Unterschriften sammeln für das Referendum, um,
deine um den Start davon zu überzeugen, dass dieses Referendum überhaupt genug Menschen interessiert,
Ja, sonst könnte ja irgendwie jeder, äh, sonst könnte ja jeder kommen. Ja, dann, deswegen brauchst du halt, um ein Referendum zu starten. Erstmal musst du ein Quorum erreichen. Und das ist Ihnen jetzt gelungen und das haben Sie jetzt auch offiziell bestätigt bekommen, dass Ihnen das gelungen ist.
Und entsprechend ähm ist da,
jetzt können kann sich die Schweiz jetzt auch offiziell auf dieses Referendum freuen, dann werden wir das natürlich äh begleiten.
Genau. Das machen wir. Hier. Bei Logbuch Netzpolitik. Und was wir auch machen, ist äh wir gehen dem Ende entgegen.
Ja und freuen uns auf die auf Freitag. Freitag, das kann man ja schon mal, also in der nächsten Sendung wird es auf jeden Fall um Julio A Sanchez gehen
da wird jetzt am Freitag entschieden
wann er aus dieser Botschaft rausmarschiert und er hat jetzt ein UN-Gremium angerufen, also das wird äh das wird hoch hergehen in der nächsten Sendung. Da kann man ja durchaus schon mal bisschen teasern.
Die haben doch schon gesagt, dass das äh wie sie entscheiden werden.
Weiß nicht, ob das ob sie das wirklich gesagt haben oder.
Brauchen wir gar nicht zu teasern, die haben gesagt, irgendwie äh alles total illegal, was da gegen ihn vorgeht und er wird einfach in der Botschaft bleiben. Von daher ist das Thema schon wieder von der Liste.
Ja, nichts passiert.
Gut, dann werden wir ihr was anderes Interessantes haben.
Genau, denn eins passiert ja nie, uns gehen nie die Ton, die die Themen aus.
Nee, die gehen uns nicht aus. Das ist ja das Traurige.
So ist es. Deswegen werden die Sendungen auch immer so lang.
Genau. Sollen wir noch einen Podcast empfehlen?
Gibt's einen, den man empfehlen kann? Es gibt empfehlenswerte Podcasts. Das machen wir später. Wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören. Tschüss. Tschau, tschau.
Tschüss. Tschau, tschau.